is advised good afternoon and a very
happy East that's all of those you all
of those of you around the world
watching this is Safari live and we have
got some vultures and the uncle whom our
pride and of course it is myself once
again with you
Steve Faulconbridge just back from leave
on camera we got Ferg
who's also just back in from leave we're
excited we are happy the life of the
Lions is going on and we have got what
seems to be the remains of a kudu kill
please feel free to send through your
questions hashtag safari live for us on
the YouTube stream let us know what
you'd like to see I've been out of touch
for the last 10 days so it's been a
marvelous leave both fergan are fresh
and we're excited and we are nowhere
near as full as that lion in the front
of the picture look at the size of that
belly
there's absolutely gorgeous itself the
area around here is completely flat from
where the Lions have been scuffling and
feeding and the big male kudu has been
shared probably relatively equally
between up the pride apart from maybe
the very smallest individual might just
have got a few scraps and we have many
many many vultures in the tree awaiting
what the Lions might leave behind a
death is going to be too much and what
we have seen already is some of these
wooded vultures because the majority of
those trees in they are actually hooded
vultures Becky and Tom thank you thank
you I am back yes nice to be back so
most of these that is an immature hooded
vulture you can see by the brown dark
plumage on the head the rest of my
adults most of them anyway and hooded
vultures in my opinion of the most
reliable vulture when it comes to
finding meat and animals so Lions with a
kill for example look where the hooded
vultures are and directly below them is
where you'll find the meat so these poor
vultures and what a disgusting way it is
to experience their afternoon they are
landing on the floor and they are
feeding on yes they are feeding on line
droppings sorry about the aerial there
those two are now fighting over certain
line droppings because that is all that
the uncle Houmas are gonna leave these
vultures
and it is a way of life for them it is
the protein source that might sound
quite revolting it's all of us out there
there you can see the beautiful pink
heads quite narrow beak and that sort of
v-shape whites on the chest beautiful
birds in my opinion very important for
the environment
vini you'd like to know how long would
it take these lions to digest the meat
of any probably two days at the at the
earliest
they'll by that stage they'll probably
move off to feed again but their tummies
are completely full they won't need to
eat for another week they will but they
won't need to you can see that when
there's nowhere near as full as this
youngster in the foreground but the Sun
is slowly coming out it is 28 degrees
Celsius 82 degrees Fahrenheit it is a
nice relatively cool afternoon in Douma
in the sabi sands and it has been a very
hot week building up to this and I think
the lions are enjoying a little bit of
the respite it's not too much shade
around where they are at the moment but
they're making do of very small branches
and is guarding the kill with absolute
purpose a cadet huge breathing because
as you can imagine all that meats
pushing down on the diaphragm forces the
forces it up and then the breaths are
very short
hello again Vinnie you wanna know
vultures have permanent homes or follow
food very that generally will have
colonies for example white back vultures
will nest in colonies could it Volkers
I'm trying to think I think they just
have normal nesting sites sort of spaced
out from each other
um Cape vultures will generally be up on
cliff faces same as lappet-faced vulture
'z but they can be very very far away
but every single morning when the heat
and the thermals start rising the
vultures will descend or ascend from the
place of rest and they'll go up high
into the sky spreading out since a very
large network of birds and they've got
very keen eyes and as soon as one of
them drops doesn't matter how far away
it is it causes a ripple effect which
forces vultures from many many
kilometers in either direction to come
through and to find the exact same meat
as the first individual so they help
each other with that okay so on that
note we're gonna go over to miss mccurdy
who has found herself a little family a
family of disappearing pigs swine's good
afternoon everybody and welcome to the
sunset Safari my name is Taylor and on
camera with me today is VM it's so
glarey looking back that way okay right
we're gonna get on the move now lots of
exciting things have happened during the
day husana was brandy still sleeping on
the damn wall he's now gone
can't find him but I'm sure he's about
somewhere uh-huh
I'll see you pigs they're actually
warthogs they're you know they think
they're invisible now and then kangana
thank you to all of you who tagged me in
the screenshots are watching the carcass
cam visited the carcass the elephant
carcass but we can't find him either
we don't really see any tracks of
leopards crossing out so we're just
going to have a little scratch around at
the moment we do have our rain roof on
at the moment true so you will be seeing
black bars could of coming into frame
every now and then please do watch out
for that oh no you don't you just have
to watch them as we go past them it's
very glarry today I suppose it's because
it's been cloudy and overcast all their
eyes have
the chance to adjust to the light so
what we're going to do is I think we're
going to go quickly check treehouse Dam
have a look there and then we'll come
back onto elephant carcass towards twin
dams and go back down to and dams trick
turn downs again all the jackal berries
checking the Malati and hopefully find
some leopards for you at this afternoon
the gremlins have already got Tristan
can you believe it the Easter gremlins
yeah we didn't even bring any chocolate
out on safari today I've just been
eating chocolate I did a chocolate for
breakfast this morning was very nice so
delicious and wasn't Easter eggs though
it was just normal chocolate then we did
also have some Easter eggs we were
fighting over the Lindt chocolate with
there was a trading process that was
going on in camp wasn't working very
well and as no one wanted to swap out
cuz you know I told you I don't like
those marshmallow Easter eggs
no one retrieved me and I thought I was
doing a good deal like swapping six of
those for like one length chocolate but
no one would swap with me but they will
take your base the G trade you was
before me I think Rebecca got in and she
scooped up the deal before I was you
know gonna fix Oh screw why would you do
that why on earth would you run out
underneath my tire I didn't get it that
was terrifying I was not even in I don't
think I was in second gear yet and the
squirrel just decided to come out the
graça the marula not in its mouth like
right underneath my tire but it made it
through why it's safe it's alive sure
that was a close call for that squirrel
hey that wouldn't have been very nice
perhaps Rebecca perhaps it was stealing
chocolates
so we'll just check yeah we'll miss it -
a net not I need to stop saying to
announce we're almost at tree house Stan
or have a little look-see
now if you have it then you just joining
us for the first time on a safari of
course a big welcome to all of you
remember you can ask us questions
hashtag safari live but it's a bit most
of you probably spending time with your
family
instead of watching us today but please
keep us company because we're all at
work when you all spend time with your
family and I hope to get stuck with a
sponge you know sent through your
thoughts and I'm sorry you feel for you
today just jokes just jokes also my mom
said that they used to bunny left me
chocolate and pyjamas at home I then
inquired about the Pringles she said no
not this yes I mean talk about tradition
breaking it unacceptable okay what do we
got at the dam what do we got here sure
are you kidding me not even mr. and mrs.
blacksmith Lapwing are here today via
aren't you shocked
they're always yeah I think I just see
it who's on there if we go to the right
there's some birds moving on the end is
that little Sandpiper anything so and
maybe a dab of salt you go a little bit
further to their own who just landed
there huh what even are you Ohi grad
hello juggler looks like ones she it's
very clear you mean I'm supposed to have
a look with my binoculars and it's very
canary we'll keep looking around for
things that have spots on them maybe
we'll find a nice day or two off you go
back to a Steve whose lions are pretty
warm
I'm sure Taylor would be dying to find
you an easter egg or two we are here
within kumis and we have moved around a
little bit just to get a a nice look at
these females here we have in picture
the one that I believe is called pretty
she has got the the damage to right eye
when she opens that you can see it's got
a bit of a purplish tinge to it and
that's probably blind which makes her it
doesn't take away a little bit of her
advantage as a predator but as I've said
before being in a pride gives her the
strength and ability to still manage to
feed and be quite successful and what a
pride of this is indeed and as you can
see them panting folk
has been a few ablutions that have gone
on while you have been away from us and
the wind is very unfavorable for us the
vultures are loving the the lion
excrement and the smell I must be honest
with you ladies gentleman is is
something that you would not quite
comprehend Fergus giggling as well he's
trying not to shake the camera but the
Lions always gonna do something like
that they're always going stand up and
look at you and then defecate and then
just kind of give you this this knowing
smile of yep the wind is blowing towards
you now I said they are very full it's
not too much left on that kudu carcass
just the main the main sort of cervical
vertebra and on the back and it seemed
from what we could see from our vantage
point that all of the meat is gone so
they'll be leaving probably the bigger
bonus for the scavenging ah heinous it
was really quite interesting on our way
through seeing lots and lots of tracks
on the road obviously tailored told me
that then goomer's are here so I knew
where we're going but there was all
sorts of interesting activity from
probably yesterday from where the Lions
are chasing hyenas and tracks of hyena
and lying all over the place with a bit
of rainfall
I really really loved seeing those
scenes I love to be able to to to watch
it you know go back in to to replay and
that's what's so wonderful about
trekking as you can gosh you can kind of
see read the bush newspaper as my
trackers used to tell me and they can
see and tell you things that you just
can't quite perceive and it's quite nice
to sort of put that back into
perspective and to try and investigate
everything that went down
Vinny wants to know if they book the
breathe quickly to help digesting or is
it to cool down well there's another lot
of cooling down needed but they do a lot
of the cooling down through their feet
but that's because the diaphragm is
pushed it's very very it's very very
full stomach the diaphragm is pushed up
so their lungs are are restricted for
the movement so they're having to
breathe like that to get enough oxygen
just to maintain their normal body
process it would be almost impossible
for them to run at the stage because
there would just be out of breath very
very quickly it's almost like going
higher in altitude you know the
compression or the the oxygen changes in
the air and so it becomes more and more
difficult to breathe it's kind of like
that they're just got a restriction in
the lung capacity and this is the lady
with the injured injured bottom we've
all seen that injury it's looking far
better than I did only two weeks ago and
I last saw this pride but you can see
with her full belly
that's going to do her very very well in
the healing process so another injured
candidate in the pride who is still
doing very very well because of the
assistance of her sisters in injury like
that or a blindness in a leopard would
make it very difficult for them to still
maintain good condition hello Roberts
you'd like to know if all lions have
names no Roberts not all lions but um
what happens with the show is that
people like to get more involved and to
try and follow the characters so
definitely on safari life there's
there's names
whenever I've worked in the past we've
only given the pride name we've never
really given the individuals names
purely because the dynamics can change
and I think a lot of people fall in love
with the characters and if they do
disappear becomes quite difficult to
deal with but if you if you're in a
large reserve with multiple prides
coming in and out it's very difficult to
keep focus on the individual names I
find anyway but here with what we do
spend a lot of time with these animals
so it is quite an asked for us to follow
their lives and their stories and as
you've probably know all our leopards in
the area have got very good characters
and names and we follow them or all of
you do at home followed in very very
well isn't she beautiful
until finger grass and front
it's almost too uncomfortable for her to
lie down she's so full so she's between
what am I going to do
she for I think it's an ugly fake she is
a shame and that's an enormous tick on
the side of her face de Costa would you
like to know what big cats hunt the most
well all the big cats hunt who hunts the
most is really hard to say it's all
about being hungry so a large pride of
lions would have to hunt more than
leopard because they've got more mouths
to feed but a smaller part of lions
would have to hunt less if that makes
any sense
and then cheetah Matt hunt more than
other cats purely because they lose
their kill oh did you hear that shed a
little bit of expulsion of air as she
laid army we hope the wind is still
favourable so I hope that answers your
question all the Quetzal hunt win need
be and they'll hunt on necessity and
they'll hunt just out of pure instinct
I've had a leopard with a baby zebra and
two warthogs in the same tree that he
caught in the same morning because we
saw him catch the zebra and then by the
time we got there in the afternoon he
had the two warthogs so he didn't do
that because he was hungry he did it
because it just appeared in front of him
and he grabbed all he could those of you
who watching the last TV show will have
seen who Kamui how he killed the warthog
and then stashed it and then shortly
after its killed a Steinbach that's his
instinct they just will catch what they
can whenever they can so I hope that
answers your question but hunger is
definitely what drives them to to
feeding ok thanks so Tristan's finally
eaten all his chocolate and there's
ready to join us this afternoon let's go
over to him and see what he has for you
no I have not eaten all of my chocolates
even facts actually I've been fairly
good I haven't eaten most of them it's
because Gerry ate all of them and that's
why I none of us have any Easter eggs as
Steve mentioned my name is Tristan on
camera I've got a Craig aka the Batman
Craig did your thumb even go through
past the lens there yes I did okay
excellent rate likes the lower left-hand
corner of the frame apparently anyway we
are out and about we have had a few
little issues because brains obviously
had a little temper tantrum because well
even though we didn't have our big
cricket game we had a little boys
cricket game didn't we Craig and what
happened in our cricket game Craig
brains got in arts a lot didn't he yes
print it was brains interesting we had a
competition who could get who art and
Prince was I got him out three times and
Brenton get me out once so we all now
have to give brains a bit of trouble
tomorrow because otherwise he's going to
be a situation where he's going to tell
you all that he bettered for the longest
which might have some element of truth
to it but he definitely didn't he didn't
have my number as he said there was no
psychological advantage and he's going
to bleat about LBW which is called leg
before wicket and how he got me out but
that's not really going to be I apply
because we didn't have an umpire and so
there's no way of telling it's a 50/50
call either way and I said I was not he
said I was but that's what's happened
now Rebecca says is because we didn't
tell her and that's why she couldn't
come be an umpire fix it was just it was
kind of a warm-up a friendly between the
boys that we decided to play and then it
kind of got more and more spicy as it
winds as you know boys can't play a game
of a friendly cricket because otherwise
it's just you know it's not how we are
we all built to be super competitive
Conrad was definitely the player that
hit the ball the furthest from the
hardest and was just trying to kind of
murder that cricket ball well not that
cricket ball but a resemblance of a
cricket ball and the rest of us were
trying to just play the patient's game
but Conrad definitely was the one that
was hitting at the hardest which was not
really big way to go on our game because
we had all these funny little rules and
actually the harder you hit it the more
you got out and then there was Craig who
was who was the surprise brains couldn't
couldn't handle Craig's bowling as all
the other couldn't get Craig also Brent
was getting really frustrated as the way
Craigslist was handling himself so
anyway it was a successful morning's
crickets and was a bit of fun and we had
a good laugh and we had a bit of a joke
around with it
no I'm sounds worrying anyway I'm going
to send you off to tell you Korea
apparently is no longer a guide but now
has become a fashion stylist before you
get to see what's happening I'm trying
to finish maurices outfit okay okay okay
I can't get almost because it's kind of
falling off maurices boy but he's
retrain D okay there we go
this is just for you wondering if
Maurice had a new Easter outfit yes
obviously Oh fancy does Maurice look
still day today he hasn't taken a bath
since he was first brought into this
world hey we'll have to figure out how
to make him shoes I bet I come in the
wrong career I mean you you don't even
want to know what I've made this outfit
out of but I've made it for things that
have come from my camera box I think
it's fabulous more easy gorgeous now at
least he's 86 years old I don't know if
I can tell you how many chocolates at it
because I think your mom will be upset
with me and Oh Billy not Ellie I believe
velly velly velly velly velly Billy
behind Billy that's you see I've had too
many chocolates too many I'm trying to
think
now back I had too little oh my sorry
the my signal is also great today but I
had to East eggs like that's one had
coconut in it the other one had
strawberries and then I also a probably
half slab chocolate so baby there we go
don't do what I did but I'm an adult I'm
allowed to do these things so that's
something to look forward to when you're
a little bit older right or if you go
back to
Steve with the nines yeah yes thanks for
that insight Taylor well we've moved
around again and we've now got this
young those looks like almost a young
male but I think it's a female there's
one of the youngsters in the uncle Homer
pride and you can't see it now but we
might get another look talking about
feeding and feeding aggressively the
right eye of this individual is has been
smashed and so the left Alex okay but if
we look at the right uh maybe it'll turn
back to us you will see that the the eye
is completely black inside and it's
probably from feeding probably got a
massive claw in the eye itself during
the the festivities or during the the
competition that goes down when lions
feed
hello suzi you'd like to know if lions
have a third eyelid like domestic cats I
have no idea I have no idea but we're
just sorry we just missed it there the
other lion to the back he just walked
off with what looked like a kudu lake
but we'll go around short and have a
look of it I want to show you this
I saw a fig this youngster I have no
idea maybe he's any of the other viewers
out there can help Suze you the question
about the third eyelid I'm not aware of
that at all but there you can see just
where the fly is moving on the eye
itself that's very bloody and very dark
and the pupil inside looks very very
badly damaged from what I could see but
Lions off there we go look at that the
eye is not in a good state it actually
opened it earlier for us and you could
see inside the entire pupil was just
bloodshot red dark dark dark bloody red
maybe it will show us I think it's to
saw but it's amazing how resilient these
animals are and how they can actually
come back from things like that I once I
wasn't physically there but company
Fergie actually worked for them called
aqua vision they're doing a documentary
at sync it's in the Kruger Park and the
two of the guys who on the vehicle the
cameramen in them and the guy who was
driving the one prod the mountain
project she jumped onto the back of a
hippo and the hippo tried all it could
to try and dislodge the Lions and then
turned and grabbed one of the lionesses
by the face one of the tasks went in
behind the eye and one wins in
underneath the chin and it picked it up
just like a rag doll and threw it away
and we've thought shorty that lion to
die but within two to three weeks she
was walking with the pride as if nothing
had happened but she never regained the
use of that one eye because I think the
test going in behind would have severed
probably the nerve endings there but
that is the thing with lions that are in
prides so they can support each other as
you've seen with the other two adult
lioness that are not in the best shape
but still look in pretty good condition
but this youngster is taking a beating
quite early on in life
but what one kill you only makes you
stronger not panting as heavily as the
others I wonder if it got as much of the
meal looking quite fool
hello Vinnie you want to know if the
other lines will help clean the eye I've
seen that I've seen Lions cleaning their
eyes for example that lioness I was
talking about for the hippo you had the
other lionesses coming up and trying to
lick the wounds
it wasn't received very well because it
was very painful but they were still
willing to do it and it'll probably
happen but it it looked very very
painful that I to me I figure you
thought so too at the time but I'm not
sure that's nothing untoward has
happened to it and it'll be fine it's
maybe just a bruising but this is trying
to open it Oh shame looks like it's been
in the boxing ring with Mike Tyson
for a lion but that is what happens
Archer that's why the feeding and
competition in lions is so important for
their survival because you know you've
got to get stronger and if you can't
survive at the feeding time then you
will not grow up to be a big and strong
individual so it starts off a very very
young and that competition for for the
feeding is what makes them stronger
hello Aidan h6 I hope you're having a
fantastic Easter wherever you might be
you want to know if can the lion put
medicine in its eye
I wish it could Aidan but they don't
they don't they'll probably just lick it
and their saliva is actually quite good
for cleaning wounds far better than
you'd think
but they don't they don't use plant
material or any medicines Archer and
being wild animals we are not going to
interfere and and assist this animal
anyway if it got injured through any
means that was related to human incident
then often game reserves might intervene
but if it's a natural thing happening
out in the wilderness and this probably
would have been just over the meat that
it got injured by one of its own family
members so no there's nothing we going
to do and nothing that the lion can do
apart from weighted out and and just
lick it and keep it clean itself and the
saliva actually is a very very very good
cleaning agent for the wounds inside of
these cats which I've seen and as you've
seen on that other individual with that
big wound on the back there's been
nothing done there apart from just
pulley licking I mean every time we see
her this flies and maggots and things
okay so we're going to stay here at the
Lions a bit longer let's go to Tristan
who's got a bird of prey well good luck
with the Lions we have found one of our
favourite Raptor characters that we see
out in the bush which is in the African
Harrier Hawk and there is a few of these
guys at fire and I think this is the one
that we see a lot on quarantine to see
it flying from dead tree to dead tree
and it's posing ever so nicely against
the rather sort of grey cloud base at
the moment but it's kind of just sitting
in the dead trees and taking it very
easy and every now and then it sort of
fluffs up its hidden it kind of turns
and looks around and you've got
dive-bomb the bit just now and it flew
from one dead tree to another and lots
of grey go away birds were long calling
at its but I wonder if it's looking for
hunting or if it's just kind of sitting
around taking a bit of a break they do
fly around a lot these birds and
generally short little flights from one
of tree to another as they
scavenger on will scavenge but search
for food and you'll find they kind of go
in and they put their feet in two holes
and pull out all kinds of things like
squirrels and birds and even scorpions
now we're talking about scorpions this
morning and trying to find them and so a
tree like that's that it's sitting in
one of those dead trees is lots of loose
bark is scorpion paradise and so that's
why these birds or sometimes go into
them and use those long legs to try and
find those scorpions in amongst that
bark itself the rivendell is a nice
looking bird isn't it this kind of
beautiful yellow face and yellow legs
with this grey sort of wing structure
and a heavily barred tail it's a when it
flies it's one of the most sort of
diagnostic features is that big bars on
the tail you might have seen it there as
it opened its wings and its tail kind of
opened out and funny enough Ravinder you
this bird actually can change its face
color so you can go from yellow to red
and that's when the bird is excited it
flushes that red color and it happens
quite quickly it's almost like you
blushing or you know when you go kind of
a bit red like that that's kind of a
hard work so it's a interesting thing
it's not many birds have that ability to
flush their color as quick as what these
guys you know see look it's walking
around on the back and it's probably now
looking for any signs of anything so it
walks along them and it sees a little
hole or it's notices something or some
movement and then it'll try and kind of
hunt whatever that is and that's goes
like I say from lizards to squirrels to
birds all the way to scorpions which is
pretty amazing and they do do a lot of
walking on trees even though they look
like they obviously have a beautiful
wingspan and they can fly they are able
to walk around on trees as well there's
a bit obscured Naser well let's trust
you maybe we can get a bit of view of it
again I might fly away these guys do
sometimes are a little bit off they are
a little bit flighty at times so we'll
see whether or not it's going to stay
still
so scenic egg is laid by a ostrich that
is the biggest egg in Africa an elephant
bird that used to lay a bigger egg than
ostrich and then but those are extinct
so ostrich is currently the biggest egg
and then the smallest egg is an
interesting one Africa is a big place
I'm not a her percent sure about Africa
but in southern Africa it's I think the
penduline tits that lays the smallest
thing I might be wrong but it should be
the penduline tits in particularly here
it should be the penduline tits but in
terms of of the whole of Africa not 100%
short to be honest I'd have to try and
see if maybe Steve or Taylor know the
answer to that question as to whether
they are whether there is a bird within
Africa that has very very small egg I'm
sure some of you might be able to help
us out as well so hashtag safari live on
Twitter YouTube chat if you have an idea
of Africa's smallest egg layer I'm sure
it's documented somewhere I just
honestly can't remember for the life of
me I'm pretty sure I've read it too but
I just seriously can't remember maybe
it's cause Easter Sunday and the brain
is not doing well it's just all about
chocolate today I suppose and that's
maybe why the brain is not working in
Kakuma trucks from last night's so
wonder if there's anything lying at this
pan that's going to check this pan and
see if there's anything drinking from
the Pangolin track pan would be so nice
if there was once a Pangolin on this
Pangolin track now while we do that
let's send you back across to Steve who
I believe is about the Lions now feeding
off of the carcass
yes sir tea the penguin would be
fantastic and I think we would abandon
everything here and rush over to see the
penguin ourselves I've only ever seen
one before my life with no with
absolutely no no evidence for that which
was quite disappointing so always have
your phone or camera when you're going
to find a Pangolin so here you've got
what is the remainder of some kudu legs
and there's not much left you see lots
of flies there's some ants and if Ferb
just zooms back a bit you'll be able to
see now that patch there that big bloody
sort of messy patch where the kill
happened and where the feeding took
place and where the Lions disturbed the
ground there's a lot of blood there's a
lot of fur there'll be a lot of maggots
and all sorts of flies that land there
and what it is is that's now a little
different hotspot so differences have
changed in the community the grass has
been flattened there's different
dynamics or if regards the the rumen
content would be spilled out there when
the vultures come down and feed their
their faeces will go into the mix the
Lions feces so the small little area
that the Lions have been in with the
dead could have formed a nice little hot
spot or change in the community dynamics
and I know those of you who've been
watching the show I've been keeping a
breast slightly in all about the
elephants at caucus not too far away and
you have a look at the ground around
that and that can stay like that for
years because of the amount of
disturbance that has happened from the
Lions feeding the hyenas feeding from
the elephant bones from the skin from
all the vultures I mean vultures that
Park in a tree if you park your car
underneath and they defecate on your car
I will actually strip the paint so they
got very very powerful digestive juices
so numerous numbers of them on the
ground feeding and squabbling for the
last bits of whatever meat might remain
often lead to as I'm talking about a
beautiful hot spot that can remain in an
area for a very long time and different
communities will grow their different
fertilizer regimes happen the blood and
the the fecal contents together form an
interesting dynamic
and a little bit of a fertile spot there
you can see the difference in the size
of the hooded and the white back in
actually the one on the left is an adult
hooded the one on the top it looks like
is a bit more Brown on the head but then
the face is quite pink but it almost
looks like a juvenile and the white back
witches is bigger you can see quite
noticeably bigger but hooded vulture is
the smallest vulture that we found and
not often seen in large groups this is
the most I've ever seen I counted 17
just now which is the most hooded
vultures I've ever seen before which is
awesome okay so I hope you're all
finding your Easter eggs
Taylor's busy searching for something
that's also hiding in the grass I've
eaten them all areas guess we've got
yeah we've gone to our family of three
warthogs that we've been seeing over the
past few days I thought you'd like to
say hello to them running away from us
unusually but might be because there's a
helicopter that's taken to the air and a
lot of the animals don't actually enjoy
well helicopters now we were obviously
inspecting maurices outfit I forgot to
show you you won't believe it this
elephant he's going through a phase in
his life now where he had a piercing
down he's got a nose ring now don't you
love maurices nose ring and then what
did you save it looks like Easter but he
he's trying what did you say he's
trunking what was something else anyone
and he's trunk tastic now Rebekah's very
quiet so I don't know she likes the fact
that maurices got a piercing we can make
him take it out he doesn't need it
listen to Rebecca giving such mom advice
she said he's a teenager and that he can
keep it for now because one day he'll
realize that he doesn't need it here we
go
advice for the day did you hear that
Maurice you don't need no pissing x'
like me I don't even have my ears pissed
can you believe that I'm too terrified
which is a a lot of people laugh at me
and they don't understand because I have
tattoos but I have a phobia of the
needle going through and through
that's too terrifying what are you
charging at sister killer where are you
obviously nothing important because you
flew away okay false alarm they're from
the Cystic you know sometimes they do
just shock now we're on children and we
weren't winning around twin dams
unfortunately being in yeah there's a
little black and white bird like there
somewhere was a bit of black back path
back that was about here is a folktale
drunk it's also just fine when we got
the roof on which is a little bit
difficult we said we weren't gonna do
too much braiding today but the other
animals don't want to come out and play
beautiful folktale drunk are very easy
to see with that red eye did you see it
again
who's that yes hello there's the black
backpack back nice nicely done VM also
got a red light is two of them moving
about on the street also looking for all
sorts of little insects and things I
haven't seen the black backpack back for
a while and they make a cool calls like
one of the few bird calls I can do they
go like this
[Music]
only not good enough there well let's
see if I roll if we can get closer to
them I can also hear a transport betters
calling to adjust me somewhere come on
birdies man I'm not a real bird
obviously again we'll carry on so what
we gonna do now I'm going oh look at
that one there we go
[Music]
beautiful go away bird sitting very very
close to the tree I don't often get them
sitting so close you see how we've even
started speaking softer and do not scare
this bird away because it is not very
often we get such a close for you and
all the Flies
oh well that was pretty cool though just
sitting up in a lead word now where they
normally sit but difficult though with
the rain roof anyways oh we go back to
Steve we're gonna try and find in Ghana
behind the dam wall oh I hope you do
find in Ghana I haven't seen him in so
long it's been about a month for me I
think since I've seen since I seen him
way too long it's about time he showed
himself but we are still with the Lions
they're not doing too much later
gentlemen but like to just continue that
discussion about the importance you know
and how everything works in the
ecosystem first of all there you have
the Lions lying on some grass and there
are some trees all around them both of
them aid in the camouflage of the cat
but the the plants provide the food and
the resources which the kudu then takes
into themselves and then the Lions come
along and their feed on them and there's
death and decay and the vultures do the
remaining feeding and the remaining
defecation and decomposition and then
you get the dung beetles and all the
beetles and flowers and larvae and
everything and slowly but surely that
all ends
a cup in the soil and the cycle starts
all over again so none of it is wasted
it is all very very well in tune with
the balance and circled life and just
for that example I've got what I found
in the front of the car here which is a
marvelous dung beetle ball and those of
you have probably seen us before in the
past it is a very very nice example of
what a dung beetle will do what's called
a nuptial ball not always the nuptial
ball but where the male and female will
actually mate the female the male will
actually create this ball and then roll
it away from the site of the food in
this case here it's going to be the the
rumen content of that dead kudu and so
then he will find a female or she'll
just find him because of the beautiful
size of this ball that is created then
they'll mate and lay one egg and inside
hatches a individual dung beetle and
very very well Rivard by the Egyptians
they look back because they believe that
the dung beetle goes through the same
process as their Pharaohs did because
they also were covered as mummies when a
dung beetle goes through this whole
cocoon stage inside and metamorphosizes
from a larvae into the beak itself they
go through the same sort of transition
as the Pharaohs hopes to do in the
afterlife so very very well looked after
and very very important nutrient
recyclers for putting everything from
the Lions dung and the vultures dung and
everything else back into the soil and
the circle of life continues so Evelyn
once you know why do lions hunt in
prides the reason they hunt in prides is
because they can take bigger prey
animals if you are one individual that
for myself example if I had to go and
try to take something down first I
better be fast enough to catch it and
second enough I've got to be strong
enough to put it down now if you're not
that fast or that strong then you can
have friends you can help you almost
like a team a football team or a rugby
team to try and play the game on your
own is very very difficult so with with
more numbers more strength more tactics
more sort ambush and some of them can
chase from this side and some can ambush
that side then with the wait in numbers
that can pull down much larger prey then
a leopard could for example and then
also bail to feed on much larger prey
and at the same time the large the pride
the bigger the territory and the strong
there will be four for defense of that
territory I hope that works Robert I
would love to find the mare lions for
you I don't know I believe they've been
seen on the property in the last couple
of weeks Ferg and I don't have the
information unfortunately I didn't spend
enough time chatting with Tristan and
Taylor about it but I will find out more
where there are some of the tracks are
saw on the way here where of male lions
but I've just got back this afternoon
so I'd love to find them for you who
knows have been there's been interesting
dynamics between the birmingham boys and
their vocal males and hopefully those
dynamics will continue into the near
future well we're gonna go quickly over
to Taylor who's got probably one of the
cutest animals ever seen there are the
cutest animals you've ever seen after
Maurice of course his cousin's the
real-life versions of him we've got a
little herd of elephants now one two
three four five six seven eight of them
just feeding behind the damn wall we
were hoping to find a tin garner laying
about but they're doing a bit of weeding
at the moment they all seem to be
feeding on a creeper I don't you know
what they're feeding on but it's
creeping along the ground then it seems
to be growing in this sort of drainage
line now this is a relatively disturbed
sort of area you can see a lot of
erosion that's gone on so I wonder what
they are feasting upon but they're all
eating it it's quite cool look actually
see if I can figure out what plant it is
but it is a bit difficult cuz I've got a
big tap root to it delicious
very very nice hello Gil so I'm watching
this other eleven what I'm so sorry
you've got plenty room yeah yes no
please don't be ugly to us because I
don't actually have too many places to
go this afternoon we're on the dam wall
thank you you've got so much space it's
okay oh yes and check cheeky tot over
yeah you're just doing that because
you've got mom next to you you're on
your own you'll be running with your
tail between your legs and they have got
a lot of room there just might be a
little bit nervous coming up on the rise
hey big girl and they're heading to the
dam we're gonna have the whole hood
actually funnel past us which would be
love me off you go
here come the rest of them and the
little baby that you'll be able to see
tooth tiny and absolutely precious chunk
we came to the dam at the right time
some of it whoopsy careful up you get
that's what happens you got too excited
gonna watch where you put those feet
little ones some of them look like
they've got wet feet and a big girl yes
yes don't worry I'm not interested in
your little elephant see how they've
tucked that little one away that one
careful steady watch yourself
mum help little ones difficult to
navigate those that treacherous train
going slowly all the big sisters and
brothers going don't worry we've got
your back we'll make sure she doesn't
get you know they're gonna decide where
they go to go now they're on top of the
damn wall I'm not gonna actually start
the car at all now cuz I don't want you
to upset their wallet on the wall you
see they were a little bit nervous of us
but I think it's because of the very
young car so we'll let them go down and
then we will make our move - yay
drinking elephants it's exciting perfect
that's how cute now that they're going
down to the water's edge we can move
well Maurice doesn't have an official
birthday
unfortunately Pradeep who is only six
years old I'm going to go this way and
then we'll look down onto them so I
don't disturb them well this is what
this is what I was going to say Rebecca
says sorry I'm told me to go back to the
Moines that okay a little bit back ci
wants me to go back just a tad just a
tad there we go
and anymore so pretty I would say that
maurices birthday would have to be on my
birthday which is the 28th of August so
Rebecca said that we had twins
you know the identical twins in fact I
don't know how I know viewpoint all
spotted that and we look exactly the
same
nice
Oh a little willows back so when I don't
know if the elephant's like and Maurice
and my stuffed toy don't tell Maurice it
he's a stuffed toy though he thinks he's
a real elephant and I haven't actually
introduced him who knows will oh maybe
one day I'll just have to toss him to
the ground and see if a young elephant
picks him up and takes him home and then
he'll be free in the wild
we'll have to taste that Arthur but then
I also don't want to lose Maurice I'm
selfish I want to keep him forever and
ever and ever and ever you'll be coming
on safari with me for the rest of my
life so can you imagine in 10 years time
when I post a picture about Maurice
he'll be ten then because I feel like
he's yeah Rebecca how old is Maurice how
old was he when we adopted him because
he wasn't he wasn't just born he was
seven last year August say training 8
this year so he's not even a teenager
yet he's got a piercing ok Rebecca's now
said in elephant years he's basically
turning 15 in human years okay that
makes me for what kind of parent would I
be the live nature
[Music]
my heart hey that's terrible okay we can
take it off no you can have it I like it
now I'm gonna my work my ring back on
now that's of course was just my ring
everybody not an actual piercing that I
gave Maurice right off you go
- I don't know who is got this vulture
but apparently there's one sitting on a
branch yes you do thanks Taylor and it
is picked up some elephant elephant
Sergei
picks up some lion dung off of the
ground with stalks and chased by the
line and now you can see look at the
crop I don't need to throat them on the
throat that is full full full full of
what I can only assume is the scraps of
Lion dung that has been picking up from
around the area but seeing as we got the
Voltron picture ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls please be at pay
attention on the 8th of April we are
having what we call draw a birthday and
Pradeep and Willow and all the other
kids out there please send through your
pictures draw a bird and send them
through to us we'd love to have a look
at them
8th of April we'd love to see your take
on the birds out there boys and girls
please simply to send them through as we
look at this beautiful vulture
Oh fantastic ok so please send them
through before the 8th of April so we
can put them together into video and
send it all out to you on that day so
please let in gentlemen different tell
your your children or tell whoever is
interested in drawing a bird would be
wonderful wonderful I know there's some
budding artists out there you don't have
to draw this bird but if you choose to
let's see how the imagination flies
maybe going draw your favorite bird or
the prettiest bird whatever you'd like
doesn't matter and we finally got a
lioness in front of us that has stood up
we wondering what she is going to do is
that amber eyes
look at her belly she is full that looks
like am buyers beautiful lioness I
always recognize her from the sighs
she's just enormous enormous cat sorry
about my hand there she's coming in
gonna come as close to us as she sees
fit you see she's just in front of us
there and her sisters are lying down in
the grass yeah let's see what she makes
of it is she going back to feed seems
like she might be she feels that gets a
little bit of leftover kudu
you might hear the noise of another
vehicle we are being joined I believe by
another game drive so apologies if they
do if there is a bit of audio looks like
Texan from we're teller there's a
marvelously cool afternoon folks and I
think the lands are ready enjoying
oh it's Rick's and actually Rick's
coming to have a look at these wonderful
vultures and a very flat fat cats bless
you is she feeding their fate can you
see I can't see ya I think she's decided
to just lie down on the food in case she
gets that little snack you know I think
some of us do that from time to time we
we wake up but in the middle of the
night we walk to the kitchen and and
while we're waiting for the toast or
whatever we have a little bit of a nap
maybe the effort it took her to walk
those 30 odd yards as taken out of it
the lioness is coming in from the right
they are not very interested in allowing
these vultures anywhere near their meal
and the gangster has stalked and chased
them a few times I wonder I wonder what
it to do if it caught it I can't imagine
the vulture tastes anything like what a
lion would enjoy eating
I can't see what she's got there for can
you see bless you oh okay that's what's
happening someone is defecating the
smell is reaching our nostrils hmm I
think it's this youngster in front of me
fig is it a young boy have a look at
that he's just in front of us just
moving around the car he's definitely
had the lion's shoe and look at that
billiard ball geing and fat it's gonna
rub heads with mum okay folks so we're
probably gonna move on from these lines
shortly but while we think about our
next movements let's go back over to
taylor with Ely's who seemed to be
thirsty we have got elephants everywhere
everywhere everywhere everywhere in
front of chitwa chitwa I always say
imagine enjoying a beverage of sorts on
the deck while watching these elephants
have a drink and that is the teeniest
tiniest full pink behind the ears I
wonder if it's not the same another one
we saw the other day with Ali that was
so small American prom to be only a
couple of days old
oh it's so tiny it was able to run quite
well actually I don't think it's it's
new but it's definitely been you know
established should have on its feet no
look at precious it is isn't it just so
gorgeous and that doesn't need to drink
water
good afternoon and welcome to at the
sabi sands private game reserve here in
a South Africa where we are surrounded
by a herd of elephants my name is Taylor
mccurdy and on camera with me today is
VM and we're very very happy to of
course bring you this live Safari so
those of you that never joined us we
welcome you greatly and all you have to
do if you'd like to chat with us is of
course comment below so we have another
look at these elephants my particular
favorite is that teeny tiny little one
which is so adorable still wobbly on its
legs and trying to color underneath mom
now this is the one doesn't need to
drink water just hit it'll be suckling
most of the time and what a privilege to
be able to sit with such a large herd of
elephants in such close proximity there
are very very few places in the world
that you can have an elephant experience
like this don't South Africa is of
course fantastic and offers you many
many sightings like this up here in the
sabi sand you know it's well known for
leopard and lion sightings too not just
limited to the big [ __ ] domes and look
at all those hippos in the distance -
just behind the elephant because the
variety the diversity of animals that
you can see when you come on Safari now
just going back to that little elephant
we saw Vanessa I'm uncertain to its
exact age that young coughs exact age I
would rake in a couple of days old as
it's still very pink behind the ears you
see that but it's not too wobbly on its
feet it was actually running mom was
running down to the water that little
one was desperately trying to keep up
with her a big girl I think she wants it
to suckle I think it's so small I can't
even fit in between it snakes no hugs
it's a hard one to say how many
elephants are in South Africa that in
the area that we're in at the moment
there is probably over 10,000 elephants
and the greater Kruger area maybe even a
little bit more I have not seen the
latest count as to how many are around
here and a big girl now I'm just
watching her
of course we are safe in these vehicles
you've just got to watch what the animal
is doing that's the most important thing
and lucky for us all the guides in South
Africa are exceptionally well trained
and especially at animal behavior hello
big girl
it's okay just watching what she's doing
she's worried about that young calf
now Selena of course this little
elephant is in danger of crocodiles most
certainly I don't think these elephants
are going to cross the dam though and
this car doesn't look like she wanted to
go swimming and they are a couple of big
crocodiles neighing after this afternoon
at Chitra Chitra so mum will be very
protective over over her her young calf
from crocodiles lions leopards even big
clans of hyenas but everybody will help
this car
oh this is so magical now they she might
be a little bit nervous to this
afternoon because that wind is just
picked up which typically inhibits the
animals from hearing as well as they
normally do an elephants rely heavily on
their hearing and their sense of smell
so that wouldn't is going to be swirling
and is pushing off of the the water and
up towards the elephants
so making their panic just a little bit
now at the moment we are currently in in
autumn in fact also happy Easter
everybody and foxy you're wondering what
is the sort of climate around yeah well
like I say we're going into autumn now
but the weather's fairly fairly good so
we don't get sort of drastic cold
temperatures or anything like that this
is actually a very nice time of the year
the rain would have stopped the wind
does pick up a little bit but most
afternoons are a fairly warm and it
looks quite dry too damn it's just it's
not the greatest soil around the dam and
in and in this area so there's not a lot
of grazing here but as soon as you move
back up into the open grasslands behind
I shall see the grass is exceptionally
tall and there's lots and lots of trees
around so this is typically a savanna
woodland biome that we experience but of
course it varies and that's one of the
most amazing things about South Africa
is the diversity not only do we have the
savanna biome and up here in the
northeastern corner of South Africa if
you go down towards the south east coast
of South Africa you start to get the
Elven e thicket which is vegetation that
is so so thick even the elephants have
trouble negotiating it and you go
further up the west coast where you get
the cape floral Kingdom which you can't
really find anywhere else in the world
very special to find the famous species
of plants so not only on the implanting
of different animals around you the
vegetation types are just in credible
and along the coastline it should start
to get rainy as we move on into winter
too
well how amazing was this to see an
entire herd of elephants art and about
and just coming down for a drink of
water I just need to watch this car very
very careful but I hope you've enjoyed
it and if you'd like to carry on
watching Safari life all you have to do
is a google it and well we'll be able to
hopefully join you soon this cars a
little bit upset right but for myself
and VM and the rest of the Safari Live
team thank you for joining and we'll see
you all soon
easy girl
it's okay relax relax relax sorry I'm
talking to the elephants like I normally
do
I reckon that this car with the youngest
cover wouldn't be surprised if she's the
matriarch of the hood she seems to be
leading up in the front
it's very nervous but I don't blame her
when you come to the water's edge with
such a teeny tiny craft there's many
dangers here so it's good to be a little
bit cautious not stopping for a swim
having a quick drink and and then moving
on I'm probably won't follow them too
much you mind we'd have to go all the
way around as you can see look how
they're all bundled up they're moving in
all sorts of different directions so
they they're a little bit uneasy I think
it might be a combination of things wind
young calves and the monks is heard
perhaps some of the cars are all
stressed
very cool to see nice to see so many
elephants again hey we definitely came
through the dam at the right time for
those of you that are also just joining
us it's great to have you we do have our
rain roof on so I do apologise for any
of the black bars that you do see that
come across the screen it's just in case
some of these cards decide to be a bit
more nastier than what they are at the
moment and I'll be settling again not
feeding though you know they're just all
turning smelling listening I wonder if
they're gonna go to one of the roads
that are fairly sandy and have a little
bit of a dust bath oh no there we go now
they're going to demolish that tree at
the back stretching up very high
feeding on only the tastiest of leaves
and that's something we got to look
forward to now as we go into winter of
course they're going to be pushing down
a lot of the trees although I think
maybe I mean this is the greenest I've
ever seen the savvy sad so late in the
year and for you
very late rains yeah which was it just
nice see now they're changing direction
again coming back towards us so I think
we're maybe we're not going to see the
elephants pushing down as many trees as
they normally do well that's the exact
reason because of the late rains I I
hope I do hope we get sick this is quite
cool to see them stretching up nice and
high I'm just gonna see what they're
gonna do now see they're going backwards
and forwards backwards and forwards
coming back around us now but probably
feel a lot more relaxed because there
were a lot of room
this is so cool how they're all stuck
together and Teva I don't think the
elephants and sort of balance with one
another
waybig's can either again but this were
the whole Easter sing so it didn't quite
catch the last part of that or where
this was going do females somehow
balance who is in Easter's and who is
not to avoid conflicts so to even know
and what you do often find is that
animals will sync their East recycles
because little ones have a better chance
of survival the more that they are very
position quickly but with elephants
elephants have got a very very very good
success rate when it comes to raising
their youngsters unlike lions and my
compiler I know that I under threat
quite often so they're actually normally
okay but I'm not so I'm not sure if
elephants would actually sink their East
recycles like like in Pilar typically
like the antelope species do I'll just
stop here I'd find them actually I
suppose we can we can do front on here
or you can do this okay very nice or
walking up towards the big tall trees
beautiful flapping there is not because
it's hot just because there's a whole
bunch of flies it's around at the moment
they've been biting myself and VM this
afternoon so I bet they're being bitten
too just stopping to feed that it looks
like they're actually going from a ruler
tree to to marula tree maybe they are
trying to find the last of the fruits
that have fallen although I feel like
they're not going to be so successful
this afternoon I feel like all those
fruits are gone even I don't think
there'll be many nuts underneath the
trees anymore because of the squirrels
very busy collecting them all now as you
all know it isn't just myself and Steve
driving around Tristan has also been out
but I'm not sure what he's looking for
perhaps he's going to try and find you a
leopard or two let's go see where he is
now
well we're trying to see if we can find
one of two lipids but at the moment
there is only signs for husana coming
slowly and in sort of easly direction
towards chip aside and maybe cut north
can't find any tracks for Tenggara at at
this stage and I was just trying to
check to one of the guys on the southern
boundary to see if they could see
something if they could hear something
but unfortunately they don't really know
they said the last tracks that they had
were coming outside so apparently we've
got tracks coming in to our side which
is good news they're just telling me on
the radio
now just gonna make another copy that
thanks very much and I'll have a look
around here maybe get lucky I'll give
you a shot to pick up anything so Shanae
is telling me that the last track for
husana cuts into this area onto our side
of the property just having a look
around you because sometimes what will
happen this is a very deep drainage line
here and it's a perfect place for a
lipid to spend time and so Hassan Oh
who's had suppose a couple days of
bumping into other lipids is probably
maybe you just maybe might hide out
inside they also it would be a good spot
for tin gana who's a little older just
to kind of go into and just race so
either one of them could potentially go
in this section so what I want to do is
just double check a few little hidey
holes and double check maybe up towards
neighborhood side cheater cut line just
to make sure that they haven't crossed
out and then if there's nothing there
then I'm gonna try and kind of have a
little look back on those tracks and
walk down into the drainage this old
hyena den is always a good place to have
a little look there's no tracks going
further east at this stage no nothing
there so it seems as though there's no
sign of any lipid kind of coming further
east maybe in that drainage line is
where the snippet is so while I check
around and just double check where it's
gone and it sends you back across to
Steve who I think has decided to stay
with those twenty cats
yes thanks very much Justin I hope you
managed to find or sauna or ting garnet
is whose tail or trail you are following
we do know you are the leopard expert
finder enormous and network of
communication that somehow manages to
get its way to you
on the leopard movements so I have no
doubts Tristan will be fortunate in his
endeavors and yeah we have one of the
beautiful lioness in the golden
afternoon light isn't that beautiful can
see the wind has just starts to pick up
a bit and two of the lioness has
actually moved off we thought to maybe
go off and drink but we haven't been
able to follow because we are surrounded
by lions at the moment so we thought we
might as well stay with the rest of the
pride and if they do get up and also go
and quench their thirst then we would
follow but there's been no other
movement and the one lioness has already
returned so I'm not sure exactly how far
away we are from tree house damn but
there are a few puddles and pools in and
around and with the rain we had recently
I'm sure there is a suitable water not
too far away to quench the thirst of
these engorged cats that is I don't know
who that is but she's too full to sit
down hello buddy you like to know what
is the purpose of the back straps behind
line is now look at her she's looking
straight at us
and you can't really see her but when
she turns around the black is very
evident
so when Lions are moving through the
long grass obviously their their vision
is black and white and most other
animals Archer see black and white so
when the Lions coming from you from the
front their face is almost invisible the
tawny color sort of disappears into the
grass but as they are moving through the
grass their intention when they're
looking in one direction the intention
of those ears indicates exactly where
they're looking and it's a silent
communication that all of those
following behind can also pay attention
to see which individual Valda based on
Paulo or zebra has that one pick
and then they can assist in basically
moving in and tackling the same prize so
from behind the eyes and the black tail
are very very obvious to any line that's
following but from the front not so much
I hope that answers your question same
as for lipids but that's the white tip
on the tail is for the cub to follow
through the long grass so I hope
everybody is having a marvelous Easter
out there and I'm sure there is lots of
chocolate being eaten not just by Taylor
or Tristan hopefully no one's gorging
themselves and chocolate the way these
Lions have gorged themselves on Carew
hello hope age 10 you asked a very
interesting question
dude lions have predators and the answer
to that hope is that lions are the apex
predator here in the savanna biome which
means there are the top predator but
that doesn't mean that they are the best
it means that they are at the top and
they need to stay there but the biggest
competitor for lions is other lions so
large prides of lions will have
competition with each other large males
will compete with each other but then
any other predator biet lion beard hyena
beard leopard will always try and kill
the Cubs of another predator if they
come across it all the individual itself
many many occasions of cheetah have been
killed by a lion by leopard hyena
killing any anyone that they can wild
dogs been killed we've documented wild
dog being killed by lioness hyenas will
actively kill the Cubs of lions male
lions will kill the Cubs of other male
lions there's lots of reasons for this
most of it is to do with competition so
it's very very interesting question but
yeah there's huge competition Archer not
just between the lion prides but between
the other predators such as cheetah even
even large Eagles even puff adders or
snakes should I say like the Python has
been known to swallow small baby cats
like a leopard for example very sad but
it is the way things work out yeah and
it is how other system continues to
perpetuate itself so should we have a
look on the side are there anything else
going on with these lions I don't think
so fake there we go just in time but
it's up hello we called that one they
haven't been doing too much movement the
kudu is practically just some bones
there and he's cuddling with his little
teddy bear believe it or not there is
the remains of a kudu behind that patch
of grass you know for maybe go forward a
touch you might be able to seat
just the horn just through the bushes
then maybe a little quiz one of those of
you out there who loved to watch this
show and spend time with us you don't I
enjoy my trees you can tell me what tree
that is above the lion now above the
kudu horn you get that one right there
fig yeah I wonder if anyone can tell us
what it is very characteristic little
red spots on the leaflets and I'm sure
many of you out there have seen this
before I have spoken about it at length
elephants absolutely love them and they
make very good furniture if you can get
big enough specimens but in this case or
in the case here in in Dru ma or the
sabi sands the elephants eat them before
they get any substantial size I wonder
how many of you out there are into your
trees this morning or this afternoon
tell me what tree that is right there
and it is not just for camouflaging the
kudu it provides a small amount of shade
a very palatable tree
so how old Rick and that cootie ball was
very probably about five to six
my pleasure hope please keep sending
your questions through anything else we
can answer for you would be fantastic
so that kudu is definitely a male as
everybody knows the kudu male and female
the sexual dimorphism difference between
male and female is males have horns and
females don't there's a slight stock
enos in the male as well and the spiral
nosov the horns there see it's a fully
mature male the tip of the horn has got
that ivory tip to it so this is a fully
mature breeding male very difficult for
kudu we talked a lot about in parlour
and a lot of other antelope Archer but
kudu in the male's dive it takes quite a
long time I can't give you an exact
number but the death of a male
especially a prime breeding male really
does impact on the breeding of the
females they don't just take another
male like the impaler's do impala males
going through their ratting the females
could could see through many many males
during the breeding season and it
doesn't seem to fit their their sort of
strategy but when a male kudos removed
from the population it almost takes the
females I don't know how long I'm need
to work on that number but it is a big
dent in their population growth so there
is something that they talk about out
there about managing populations you
need to make sure that you don't remove
large breeding bulls from a population
if you can Monique wants to know when
they killed this could you and by the
look of it it was probably last night
but I wasn't here to see it and I didn't
get too much of an update so I'm sorry I
don't know but I'm sure some of the
viewers out there who've been watching
closely I've got the answers to that
from Monique by the states of the lions
bellies and by the fact that they're
still here to me means that though it
was made early this morning or late last
night
but then I did not see it Monique so I'm
sorry I wonder if you folks can hear the
breathing now the panting of that cat
sorry about that I can hear it it's
almost I can almost feel it the power of
of I can only count ten lines yeah but
the power of the breathing in the
stillness the wind is dropped again he's
a stallion a stillness around and just
thought I'd flap of vultures taking off
and landing as we said before the the
hooded vulture being the smallest and
all is the best indicator of our finding
it meat and the only vulture who gets
too close to lions because most of the
other vultures being as big as they are
they're not able to jump out of the way
of the stalking cats that would rather
put it down to the ground and kill it so
the hooded vultures do quite well they
are quite animal and quite easily or
we're much easier than that other larger
birds in getting a little bit of flight
and to get away from the Lions
I'm still loving how green it is yeah I
know being away I didn't go too far and
he went about an hour away to to play
some now renting near good sprites
and we had some rain in the last 10 days
and you can tell by the greenery around
that definitely going really really well
nice and green pea heart thinks the tree
is a LED word it is not a LED word and
Rory it is not a Torchwood
unfortunately no those are incorrect if
you go in on that exact leaf there can
you see those little red spots on the
leaf very red spots
it was very characteristic of this plant
Judy of course you've got it it is a
round leaf teak also known as a blood
wood and quite easy to remember when you
think of blood wood because it almost
looks like there's some blood spoor
on the leaf drops of blood of an animal
may be passing by that seemed to stay in
their leaf that red spot and it is
indeed a teak pterocarpus Rotonda folia
nice round leaf and the pod resembles a
wing very nice thank you Judy for the
quiz
so there's gentlemen we have some very
flat cats this afternoon we're probably
going to leave them in the next few
moments go see if we can find you
anything else of interest so let's go
after Taylor who looks like she's on
another planet altogether we I can sort
of hear you back so now you've said live
live we're just trying to find a gap yet
what about that gap yes it's hard but
we're at the nest where the barn owls
are supposedly but we can't see anything
just yet at the moment very dark little
tunnel in there and it that's crazy
doesn't look like anybody's home said we
just thought we wanted to come and have
a look I hope that that is the right
hole OBM yeah the MVM has been here
before I haven't I think it might be a
little bit too early in the day maybe a
little bit later when the adults just
before the adults start to get a bit
more active and perhaps who get a chance
and get lucky but I mean I can't even I
can't see anything and they can just see
it but a faeces there's sort of at the
entrance which is normal and she shows
us that it's active okay well we'll try
later we'll come back we'll have a
little look and I'm gonna try and get
out of here hmm
we might have to sneak cavium I think
I'm gonna do a sneaky wait because I
also don't comes with Beck's
so let's move on along now I'm very
traumatized oh you know it's not good
eaten by the thorns so obviously no
Maurice had a piercing on his nose
there any youngsters out there that are
under the age of 18 unfortunately you're
not allowed to have any piercings you
don't need them you're fine without them
I just want you to make that clear so
don't be asking mom and dad for
piercings now coz Maurice the elephant
has one
he's an elephant of course elephants are
allowed to do what they like because you
know who's going to stop an elephant
he's big you could just squash me it was
also a clip on one you quite right for
Becca look goes like this from my hand
onto his trunk so you can have one of
those you're gonna have a clip-on nose
ring you're going to be having a real
one so trying to drive Maurice you're
getting a lot of attention today my boy
because I'm gonna lose that nah be upset
that slice and put that back on so we
bumped into Sheldon from chitwa chitwa
had a little chap to him when he says
he's been watching that young little
elephant pull over its feet for the past
few days he's been required entertaining
and so that happened and and then I also
got an update from him and he said that
one of the Arethusa guards
Roy and actually saw leopard tracks
crossing some incident gallery from twin
Dan so I don't know who had across the
road it could have been Tenggara it
could have also been horse Anna and I
she said to him I was like well that
makes sense because there were a couple
of nobbled backs the females they
normally live at the Boone pen which is
the sort of pans on the opposite side of
the road from twin downs and they were
now in they were in two and dance and
then I normally swim around and they're
normally on the other side so that makes
a lot of sense ever a leopard cat went
strolling on through I suppose because
they're very quick we can say hello to
that Impala very briefly
hello impala how are you not interested
showing us his bottom that is hard and
interested he isn't us today he just
wants to eat eat eat eat that lovely
beautiful animals overlooked definitely
one of the most overlooked animal
species we get here in Africa equipped
with beautiful fighting horns lovely
ears big black eyes they've got beady
eyes and will not be Diaz and small but
sort of a colour just keeping an eye out
we're gonna see quite a few animals
coming out into the open especially
tonight with all the clouds with all the
wind
quarantine is going to be bustling this
afternoon you can see it's pretty
miserable out there Oh who regard to
settle build stock well done VM very
nice just getting lost behind the trees
a bird that I have not seen for a very
very long time
oh no it's going to go in land oh if it
is going to go and land so we go around
and see if we can find it again
it's Ferraris fiery to the settlements
talk I'm gonna get in the right yeah I
can still see the stalk flying in the
distance so we're gonna race on after it
and see if we can find out where it's
going to land change my Rachel's going
south now Tristan is still on a search
for leopards hopefully he's that much
closer well we are searching and we've
got tracks war husana that's just going
all over the place up and down kind of
back and forth and the last truck I had
was on laid wood Road kind of going east
towards the torch would cut line but I
don't see anything crossing out so I'm
just trying to do a few loops around
I've just come up towards Mamba using
drakensberg and now I'm going back
towards cheetah cut line just to make
either person sure he hasn't crossed out
but he seems that he's been a busy boy
given that he was seen at 12 o'clock
which is not that long ago he's walked
quite far he's gone all the way up carry
main he went up cheetah cut line for a
bit then cut towards labour then from
later he went back towards cheetah cut
lines he's kind of seems to be moving
quite fast and we know how he is he can
be difficult when he goes round and
round in circles as he was the other day
in exactly the same area that we're in
now where he was kind of moving about
all over the show so I'm just
double-checking to make sure he hasn't
crossed out of our area because if he's
crossed out of our area obviously then
it's going to be very difficult to find
him because we can't go there
so I'm just having a little look around
now it sounds like ting gone has been
found somewhere a little gallery chitra
area so don't know if maybe tanner can
get hold of the guys on the radio but it
sounds like maybe he's on that side at
the moment so he went from the elephant
carcass softwoods
and back in to little Gauri
it seems the husana came up northwards
towards our side which is interesting so
I'm shorting Ghana and it's obviously
he's kind of just trying to go away from
him
good now I believe Steve left his lines
but has bumped into well one of the
improvements having a little drink we
just moved out of the the siting and as
we anticipated one of the females is
here drinking so we were going the other
way and Dixon he was on his way to the
Lions and he called us
okay are we gonna go good character
Taylor who's got some interesting
activity right look what we've got I'm
just trying to get us in a good spot so
via ma hyena friend is moving and the
roof makes it exceptionally difficult so
we heard an Impala alarming in the VMO I
don't know if those in parlour a telling
story actually have a little listen you
can hear them and then that hyenas gonna
pop out here
yeah everybody is very upset not just
the Impala there's some crown lapwings
there's some squirrels now I don't know
about anybody else when I first saw
that's hyena that squirrels very angry
it looks like you know had anybody
watching Harry Potter
not not Harry's uncle the teacher he
turns into a werewolf I don't know why
this hyena kind of looks like that to me
that's what first popped into my mind so
afternoon off it goes wandering down the
road looks quite scraggly quite thin I
wonder if it is a male there's no [ __ ]
amount of massive maybe some of you
recognize it and then us know the way
it's kicking up just barely picking its
feet up it's beautiful
watch it as it disappears and then I'm
going to show you the squirrels because
they're quite funny
and I feel like they've forgotten that
we're here girls also shouting now
everybody's shouting take bin right on
the edge of this chair mark man stop
there is a little squirrel that was the
one that you could hear that was
shouting it's now stopped though hello
you frozen terrified it was got big eyes
in relation to their hair don't you
think this place is one that shotty in
the distance this one's no I'm not
worried and he was only trust when then
how unit came close to its termite mound
pretty sure it's the same family
squirrels I showed you before that live
up on a marula tree and then often come
and warm themselves this termite mound
very cool I never though hanging is
going
we can go see if we can find anything hi
that's still shouting every now and then
hyenas hunt so often in the cyber sandy
normally hunt could you that's what I
noticed they were feeding on most down
in the south and it was every well we
often very quickly get a reaction now oh
here it is again let's have another look
this is does look like there's something
funny with us my you know doesn't there
don't go around the corner we'll have to
catch up to it again something doesn't
quite look out of place and I think
you've all said you agreed I mean that
could have been a battle with another
clan of hyenas that could have been from
a lion maybe taking a swipe just
locating it
it's got a slight limp but for it just
keeps just keeps going around the bend
you see that on the left hand side there
my pots would just be very thin as well
it wasn't a guy who's got much muscle
around its back-end and hyenas are not
sort of scrawny looking animals they're
definitely well-built think p.m. we're
gonna do a maneuver hold on
I want to try and get in front of that
hyena again I'm gonna sneak around
wouldn't want it to do that we're gonna
go a little bit quickly I don't know if
we're gonna catch it or not wait I just
don't want to put too much pressure on
it from behind hold on VM we go fast my
favorite thing in the whole wide world
yeah now when hyenas communicate with
one another I'm gonna keep my eyes on
the road because I'm driving a little
bit quicker than I normally would and
just find a call whether it's a rumbling
sound or the Laughing sound will be able
to tell other hyenas in the area whether
they're male of faint with a female or
social status whether they're
high-ranking low ranking all these
different types of things that they're
in despair distressed whether they found
something to eat when they're trying to
locate the rest of their clan so yes
First Lady you're quite correct in
saying depending while we can train
esses airily tell the difference but the
hyenas will be able to tell them there's
an elephant that's just popped up in the
road as well might run into a bit of
trouble the same you know with the
elephants I don't know if we're going to
be able to get to that hyena though the
roads a little bit further no it's
actually okay yeah it is yeah hey guys
it's the same herd we saw earlier let's
see if we can see that hyena and keep an
eye out on all over the situation so
there's the road this is theoretically
where the hyena should be popping out
and it wasn't necessarily sort of racing
on down that road it was moving
relatively slowly so there's the rest of
the elephants come out from the drainage
line now and we'll have a quick view of
them and then I'll go back after this
road and hopefully we will pick up on
that hi you know again just to have a
further inspection would be nice to see
it from front on let's do that
let us do that mmm just want to scare it
either you know it is a high you know
we'll probably move off of the road we
can see that there's something not quite
right with it so I don't want to give it
a room and make it feel comfortable
we'll just go slowly now no need to race
like we were you could have also taken
an animal pathway though so I'll keep
searching all the way around some of
these animal pathways are so wide
there's a lot of hippo movement around
here and they create well they've got a
very wide berth as we've seen which does
create quite a nice pathway for the
animals to move around on other than
just utilizing the roads check this
intersection for tracks it could have
also gone to the right hmm okay well I'm
gonna try and track this I you know and
figure out which way it's gone it seems
as though Tristan's doing the same thing
but he's found the tracks of some animal
well I'm not trekking a hyena I am
tracking a lipid and there you can see
the footprint for husana and they have
crossed into Torchwood so there's not
much more I can do from where we are
these are the last tracks going along
the road and then just kind of going
across in front of me on a little
pathway and deeper into tortured and
away from us and fortunate me but it's
not the end of the world because hisana
often does this where he kind of crosses
in and out and goes in the cut line and
he's really walked on this cut line once
and him came in and then he's going out
again so let's just keep up on the cut
line and you never know maybe we'll have
him coming back out some way up ahead of
us but he basically just went straight
across and there's this little kind of
path you can see there in the grass is
sort of cut line and that's where he
just goes straight through and into
don't talk to it itself but let's just
double check you never know maybe we'll
get lucky unfortunately though he's
walked quite far much further than I
originally thought he had walked and so
that's that I'm afraid
it's a bit of a shame really you think
of two different lipids that were on the
property at lunchtime we would have had
one where the last seems as though both
of them have decided to vacate for the
afternoon Safari which is okay maybe
they're on the hunt for their eggs
that's why they're moving about as much
as they are now while I'm driving along
I want to try and just have a little
look in all these trees and all of these
kind of termite mounds just in case
there is a lipid lurking somewhere here
now while I do that that sends you back
across to Steve I'm not sure where he is
at the moment but I'm sure whatever he's
doing it will be entertaining
yes thanks Tristan we moved off from
that lioness and as soon as you cut away
from us as she finished her drinking and
then moved back to the very similar area
of that kudu kill and we have come along
and we have found family maybe of that
male whole bunch of ladies and offspring
they kind of look quite solemn in their
expression I wonder if they're know what
has transpired but I haven't seen the
male with him yet notorious a Red Bull
oxpecker doing its deed on the ears a
little bit of grooming going on you can
see the oxpecker on there on the right
now is that a juvenile just good not a
picture but a beautiful little fanny
there I wonder if they know what awaits
them only a kilometer or two away best
to not go in that direction ladies
okay well folks let's go back to Taylor
who's managed to relocate on her high
hina we did we did it was just patiently
waiting in the road now it seems to be
smelling something off to the south but
I think it is also listening to the herd
of elephants behind us I don't think
this I you know would want to run into
any trouble but a very tattered ear
which is another indication that it is
fairly low ranking like I said I think
it's a male just from looking at it I
said not particularly big and bulky like
the girls normally are now the thing
that's interesting about hyenas is a
fact that the females are bigger than
the males we typically see this with
birds and often in reptiles with snakes
but you don't normally see it with
mammals so yes Peter
the female hyenas do produce well
they've got higher levels of
testosterone than sort of normal levels
of testosterone that you'd find in any
female animal and this of course gives
them that extra bulk which is quite cool
it's VI find it very difficult to tell
the difference between the sexes and
it's obviously very easy when you see a
female that's lactating otherwise from
the outside and from a distance the
appendages look fairly similar yes
something's courted its attention I
think it's still the elephants because
even I can just hear the elephants
feeding now you won't be able to hear it
unfortunately the feeding Genki it looks
like it needs a meal now unfortunately
the male hyenas don't play much of a
role in the clan it is a matriarchal
system so was it Dan Daniel I think
Daniel sorry Biggs David close we're
going to get there that was going to be
my next guest hey David
so no the males don't play a role only
if it's if maybe it could be hunting
maybe it's gonna catch a scrub here or
something like that didn't seem to mind
us too much and so even the males that
come into a clan that are sort of fairly
well known by the dominant females well
they're not treated as well as she would
treat her daughter they're probably
bullying them a little bit so when they
come into contact with other females
from a different clan that they maybe
don't see yes hyenas are not the most
welcoming animals to other clans of
hyenas and they definitely do stand
their ground and put up a bit of a fight
I mean brent was a parental squat that
got to see that a most amazing clan war
in the Mara that was insane never seen
anything like that before seeing this
very small mini clan war if you will
once at Samba sabe around a hippo
carcass she's very keen about something
we'll follow it and see if it's got what
it's going to do towards the elephants
so we will go around and have a look and
like I said to you earlier
could you are something that hyenas love
to hunt in the sabi sand and that's what
Steve Scott
yes we're still with this bunch and they
are quite relaxed considering I mean
most the time we spend with could
researcher they're not that relaxed
Eloise you I'll say a question I'm not
sure I know that it takes some time I
need to have a look she wants to know
how long will it take a herd to get a
new bull I need to double-check it I
don't have my my facts 100% with me at
the moment but I do know that it is
quite sensitive the females are quite
picky when it comes to their mating
males and they weren't to pick the next
one that comes along he'll have to prove
himself they have to go through all
sorts of rites and rituals so to speak
in the kudu world and dominating and
fighting other males before he'll be
allowed into the breeding but how long
exactly I do not know but it's a small
family unit you know young males which
is quite quite rare I think to see a
group of that many without any charlief
universe what an interesting name you'd
like to know how many females will it
could have all have that is a very good
question you know you can hang it
between four and maybe about seven I
think that's probably half the average
it's possible in areas of higher
resources there might be more females
but then what you see here is the the
offspring as well so two three years
worth of offspring maybe even four years
when it comes to females and in the
males at like three or so are pushed out
of the hood as they don't serve any
purpose to the male and so he will
service that the selection of females
and maybe even eventually some of his
daughters but ideally not they should
move off into the harems of other males
but that is why the breeding and males
when they are breeding at any breeding
for about three to four years at the
most so gently by the time that they off
spring females are ready for mating they
have either died or being out competed
when it comes to a breeding herd so that
that makes it quite quite quite
stressful for the kudu as I said before
the impalas seem to just carry on as
but it does affect them and look at how
their camouflage behind those bushes
that herd of however many that was have
just vanished
which is exactly what their camouflage
is made to do and that's why they stand
very still
they weren't standing very still and
even though they were moving we still
lost them so what we call destructive
markings the markings on the side almost
blend in with the trees themselves the
mane of fur on the back also changes the
body shape so if you look at for example
a solid structure it's got a an actual
lion to it but if you put a mane of hair
in at a breaks at that line just very
camouflage and also the spots on the
face and the line between the eyes
changed that whole appearance of that
beautiful beautiful animal okay so we're
gonna continue on doing something quite
similar to Tristan we're checking in
little bits of water holes and also
looking at every tree and on every
termite mound I would love to see a
leopard on my first drive back in the
survey says as I was leaving my new
accommodation yesterday
I live close to its prey jumped in front
of the car and try to hand to squirrel
yes I'm so excited I just moved to place
which is very remote sits in the bush
not far from which spreads it's kind of
in a very similar area to this except
that's not open to the nettle Park the
fenced area there's definitely animals
they are source and leopard tracks
beautiful burning beautiful neck civet
eat no leopards or are no Lions in the
area you can hear them from Chris area
to the north and some variety to the
south but seeing a leopard similar plans
I believe Tristan has got I wonder
Beck's if you'd still like to go to
Tristan because you've just spotted
ourselves one of the big five a big
elephant look like a nice relaxed male
let's see
let's go live but further and see if
their behavior changes we obviously
don't want to influence their behavior
so by watching them feed gently like
that two tails are wagging
they're very relaxed so edge the car
close until some form of behavior
changes still no change
there's at least three there's a fourth
one it's a breeding head this is a young
bull here in front stall no change in
the behavior that's marvelous we'll stop
there
wonderful it's a breeding herd deficit
more down in the down in the river
depression here the dry riverbed and
also right we are Saran and there is a
very small baby coming up that slide oh
just in front of that one and there's
another one oh no there's two babies
there this is a very nice welcome back
for me I absolutely love elephants I
think I just said them we don't get
elephant where I live
and so they're showed themselves to me
but to carry on that story are saying
it's just it's amazing to know that even
in the place I'm living now they are
still lipids lipids all over the place
very resilient cats very able to to
adapt in to live in areas where where
other large predators don't seem to
manage but look at him look at the
classic elephant behavior there its eyes
are quite wide as it was surveying us
and trying to figure out what threat we
are to the environment or to to the herd
safety and it's a very good
characteristic there's a young boy as
you can see is providing us with his
fifth leg there
lion bugle Google do you want to know if
Elif elephants adult elephants sleep
standing up and they can they can lean
against the tree they can stand on just
their feet cross two legs over the other
quite often they will lean up against a
dry riverbeds or banks termite mounds
lying down flat on the ground does put a
lot of pressure on their lungs so that
is something that they do pay attention
to but I've seen fully grown male
elephants lying down flat on the ground
so it's not that they don't do it it's
just that they don't do it all the time
and they only do it for about maybe 15
to 20 minutes or so at a time I remember
when I lived in the northern Kruger in
my tented camp for wilderness up and
porphyry
often had an elephant that would come
and sleep very close to camp and sleep
on the termite mound we'd go and find
the tracks in the morning and what was
quite incredible was that it snored the
noise that came from its trunk as it
slept was yes it was very nice to hear
but quite annoying at 2:30 in the
morning when you've got to wake up in a
few hours for for a game walk but it was
quite something to to see and actually
tracked and had a look at all the tracks
yeah we've got one coming out of the the
river here folk is looking like he's
going to show us some fun little
youngster and I actually looked to the
tracks on that that termite mound that
it has been sleeping on you could see
where the legs lie and where the feet
were and exactly where the trunk was you
could actually see where the air was
coming in and out of the trunk they were
still sort of moist just sort of spittle
stains on the soil look at that here he
comes
I'm dangerous how big I am here we go do
you see the tail is up the head is up
the eyes are very wide open
Pisces I love the hugest of the ears to
Mister the youngsters coming again can't
won't make it noise
[Laughter]
I just love ha not silly they can be
okay folks are we gonna stay with these
dailies a little while longer and see
what happens but we go back to Taylor
who stole with her spotted hyena no
sadly and I was about to told Rebecca
that he is on the move and heading on
off of twitch it was so sadly we can't
follow him anymore man I don't know what
he wants to do that I don't know he's
stopping and listening maybe he's
waiting to hear the distress call of an
animal you know as a leopard catches a
Stan Walker a Dakin he's gonna race on
in and steal it who knows no I don't
know how many hyena male hyenas are
normally in a clan Raghu we typically
don't even see them around the den side
so it's normally quite difficult to say
the only time you might see an entire
clan together is that like at a carcass
when they're feeding but then even then
because of the different ranking system
some of them have to wait off at the
side and can come off at the end and you
don't often see too many males around
the den side occasionally you'll see a
few so it's quite hard to tell in fact I
mean like the Mara those kinds of hyenas
and average size was between 50 and 70
and there were some exceptional clans
that were over 150 and it's very
difficult to tell what's going on but
majority of the the members of the clan
will indeed be female or any of you
there's not gonna be an even or a close
match as far as I understand
Oh Mac it's exceptionally difficult for
female hyenas to give birth and and
that's of course because of this the
elongated will put for Taurus go down to
that as you know
oh there's both Mongoose yeah we'll see
if we can get them oh yeah I think
they're going home see if any more of
them are gonna run across the road and
so they've got this very sort of narrow
canal that the youngsters are born are
hyenas normally only have two cubs most
of Salmons even just one and sure it can
kill the female those youngsters can get
trapped inside that sort of chamber add
some obviously I coulda said it's very
narrow very difficult for them to come
out and if their youngster gets stuck
the female will most certainly die -
sometimes they suffocate on their way
out so it's it's a very very difficult
process I've actually I've never seen
that I've never even seen mating hyenas
before very very rare to come across
that right well the Mongoose we'll see
if we can see them here that the grass
is quite long I can hear them just very
high pitch to the squeaks no difficult
to see AVM I think of it too difficult
in fact it's none of the grasses long
now sorry sorry everyone I don't know
what we're going to go and do now
perhaps we'll start heading towards a
dam in Louise any see if I can find you
a hyena track and these roads have been
driven up and down quite a few times so
we might not see one just my head to the
floor we have to go back up to where we
first had it let's do that quickly sorry
Wendy
you know and then we'll see if we can
have a look from my scare one I think
even with the wind that we've had today
one of those fresh tracks will be
slightly disturbed you're just gonna go
up a little bit ahead so just bear with
us and then we'll be actually we should
see on this Junction right here we don't
even need to go around the corner okay
now we got to start looking we also
might lose the roof
santé stables - okay so it went down
that way over yeah okay here we go we've
got them but they just you know hit so
fresh you can barely see them mmm
actually we're gonna need the softer
sound here it's the sound is so fine
okay you know what I don't think that
any of these tracks are gonna work
unfortunately because the sound is so
fine and those tracks are really fresh
and the lights not great so we'll go try
and find some older high you know tracks
on the airstrip that are in the maybe
from the weights and from last night and
we're gonna head back that way which is
a little bit of a drive so while we go
and find some hyena tracks or if we go
back to Tristan I might have a beard but
my name is not Tristan it is Steve
although many of you viewers out there
think Scott my self interest in I
actually triplets maybe we should take a
photo together to show you all that we
are not so we've been with this herd
they've moved across the road let me
just try back up a bit see if we can get
another look at them as they're slowly
meander into the evening the Setting Sun
no off they go you seem to have lost
sight of him but that's okay it always
is a marvel to me how the ilis
can behave like the kuru and just
disappear into the thickets the ghosts
of die that now seem as a thief is
unfortunately experiencing a few of the
gremlin issues that we have had in
recent times and so hopefully you'll get
rid of them and shake them off so that
you can carry on viewing those elephants
that he was loving so much Caesar a good
drop back feel like I've seen absolutely
nothing and he's at Ellie's and he said
lions I suppose nice oh it's nice when
you have a good drive back and hopefully
our luck will change at some point soon
as well we haven't found any other
animals at all we've done
Quarry pan we've done before the dam
checked around Bay there was trucks for
her Kamui from two days ago but that's
about it is really not very much else at
all Nancy in terms of the temperature
and how warm it is right now I'm not
quite sure it's not very warm this
evening it's not as warm as it has been
over the course of the last few days so
I would hazard a guess that's I reckon
it's about 20 25 26 somewhere there I
suppose there's a bit of wind chill so
I'm gonna actually readjust it say 27
degrees Celsius which would be what that
would be close to 70 something
Fahrenheit so I think 70 about 70 or 80
Fahrenheit somewhere there that's what
it feels like at the moment but I'm not
sure maybe Rebecca can give me an
accurate reading from our weather
station and tell me exactly what the
temperature is
apparently it's being refreshed let's
see no I'm stopping because I can hear a
squirrel alarm calling and squirrel is
along according to my right-hand side at
the moment but I don't see anything
of course squirrels are not always the
best indicator of a predator being
around that is you know easy to see
sometimes they will alarm call
no alarm call for four Prince's like
snakes that are in this kind of grass
I'm going to be near impossible to see
so we're not going to have much luck
luck there now apparently my thermometer
is way out I was saying 2637 that was
what did I say 26 to 87 somewhere there
hey Rebecca but it's apparently 20 to 72
degrees in currently right the second
and that's I suppose a little bit cooler
than what I thought I thought it was a
bit warmer than that but there is a
little sneaky kind of cool breeze so
it's not surprising that there is that
temperatures but it's I just feel like
it's warmer than it was this morning at
some point though I was on walk this
morning and it was still a bit kind of
sticky and humid this morning where is
this evening it's got a little bit more
of a cool feel to it
so no Rebecca Rusty's fun rusty just
sounds that way Rebecca thinks rusty
might die the SIA is not dying don't
worry it's okay it's all good it's just
sounds a little different to [ __ ] and
windy but it sounds perfectly fine to me
is the normal kind of rusty it's got a
very kind of loud fan if you want to
call it that now there's some tracks
here that I just want to look at there
should be tracks for what looks like
brains and Rickson from the other day
when they were walking so we don't need
brain to Wrexham tracks although
tracking Brent would be very difficult
because that's a man that has ants in
his little pants and so often is all
over the place back and forth around in
abouts I think you'd be a hard human to
track I'm not sure actually who'd be the
hardest human in in our crew to track
what do you think Rebecca I think Brent
would be one because he's so hyperactive
that he just walks around all over the
place and Rebecca likes to go running a
lot so she would be very Rebecca says
Taylor because Taylor falls every way
see the tracks would just be constantly
kind of going and then just be flats
human print and then you'd have to find
out where she kind of walk from there so
it'd also be coffee all over the place
that would wash the tracks away that
would make it quite difficult to follow
exactly where she goes so Taylor would
be quite tough I would imagine as well
and Scotty D would be the other tough
one because also squats like brains
pretty hyperactive felon is always up
and down and round and all over the
place I mean you know car after car all
around this area I think he would be
harder to track been pretty even prints
which is saying something what do you
think great Craig would actually be
probably the hardest given that he hangs
upside down every day you'd have to lose
his track so they're suppose he would
walk to the point where he would hang
upside down and go into his little cave
where he spends the daylight hours and
then just comes out for the game drives
what do you think Craig maybe you reckon
Conrad it'd also be another one because
Conrad also walks all over the place you
rights well done great you see you're a
thinker that's why I like spending time
with you Craig
Craig actually today was the one that
solved our audio problem that we our
comms problems let's say my earpiece
connection Jack wasn't working and
Conrad came and we tried and we fiddled
and we failed and an eventually Craig
who is keeps this all a secret and
hidden I don't know why but he's pretty
good with technical things and and even
caused themselves and he doesn't really
say much about it but then Craig came to
the rescue and he fixed the earpiece and
that's what's allowed me to be on game
drive this afternoon and in rust Ian
will allow us to use rusty going forward
say well done Craig round of applause
there we go he gave Craig a good round
of course that was a Wimbledon clap if
you've ever watched the the Tennyson
were moving that's how they clap you
know it's very prim and proper who's one
is in Wimbledon Tennis Club it's
actually Queens doesn't it Queens tennis
table no that's the Queen's tournament
what's it called again
I forget the name now but they clap like
this very kind of you know what's what
and what to make sure that you cap prim
and proper and no se tracks for a lipid
here as well hang on a second this might
be actually vasanas tracks coming back
again I just want to double check these
quickly in a nice area because we had a
bit of rain during the day today and if
there's no spots of rain on top in these
tracks will be quite fresh no all you
tracks I don't see you anymore
[Music]
so it doesn't look like there's any rain
on top of them trying to find a nice
kind of clean one here we go
I just want to have a quick check of
them it's difficult for you to see I'm
afraid unfortunately I park very badly
but they might not have any rain on them
they very very kind of soft there's no
crustiness to the track and when you
have a bit of rain like we had this
morning the road gets a little harder
and it gets like a little crust on it
and so when you touch it it kind of
doesn't give away when when it's fresh
and you touch it that Hulka sand just
crumbles away and it's very very soft so
he's actually don't look too bad I'll
have a look around for these they go
back in the direction I just came which
is interesting so while I try and kind
of have a look at these and check what
they do it sends you back truster Taylor
who I believe is taking off we've
actually just put a halter to our
takeoff because we thought we'd
appreciate a moment with the Impala and
the beautiful sunset which is just in
the distance so standing here like I
said everybody's going to be coming out
into the open and that's exactly what
the pot empire are doing I forget then
it's not two Impala and one parlor
actually don't comment because this will
be very long and so yes so lovely heard
of him pilot oh my goodness must be
about 150 of them around you easy huge
gatherings at the moment as the rutting
season gears up all females coming
together maybe they were looking for
their suitors to see who the contenders
going to be this year for 2018 rutting
season who knows more casually crossing
the airstrip and see we're just
surrounded by them at the moment could
almost you could well if we could if the
cameras could go around 360 degrees you
just see Impala everywhere it's
never-ending
there's a black fire again of course
we've got the rooves on another one
another one some sinners oh what a
surprise
one parlour that's beautiful there very
peaceful out here too
I think it's gonna be a little bit
change night well I'm feeling a bit on
the cold side right then
seatbelts on please is it fastened tray
tables up in the upright position
yes p.m. no he's obviously flow in a few
times as you can see because we are a
body go okay right good am I sure that
was unpleasant have to replug myself in
you ready for this ridiculous right one
of those a host this is jump very untidy
to be an air hostess though however and
I do not have my hair and you do the bun
hey cuz I was over here in a bun so I
could do that just stick that and I hear
what long hair so we can just actually
stick the tail in my hat sort of I need
the scarf ething hang on how does it go
view it's not very neat this ray caspo
told me to not say things like my the
ones I just say them okay does that Mike
find you what else do I need
I can't are you reading because you know
they always they smile rediculous bigger
smiles you've ever seen in your life I
don't know who would want to be that
excited I'm excited about what I do this
is cool right good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen and welcome aboard you'll fly
to the two one six eight five nine five
Boeing seven three eight hundred and my
name is Taylor and I am the chief
hostess this evening and I'll be well
helping you attend to any of your needs
at flying the plane this afternoon is
their captain dr. V M because you know
he's also got a medical degree I don't
wanna do this anymore
right let's do emergency it's for those
of you that are worried that the plane
might crashes and of course just a joke
everybody I'm not being serious we have
got at for emergency exits we've got two
over here we've got two down on the roll
on that side and well if you're feeling
brave you can also just go straight back
behind me and over the hood of the car
and off you go
right the police fasten your seatbelts
and as the captain said earlier tables
up and armrests on and peace mate
sure your seat is in the upright
position should you experience any
turbulence please do and not be afraid I
don't know turn your volume on your
music up a little bit more and we'll
enjoy the ride I don't know how much
trouble I'm going to get into for doing
all of that yes I'm just joking to all
the air hostesses I think you guys did a
fabulous job job well done the things
that I've heard people say to a hostess
is well done for not saying anything
back I normally comment for them I've
heard some very appropriate things here
and there also I don't think I'd want to
spend my day up in an aeroplane although
you get to travel though which is pretty
epic you get your code go to all these
you I her destination all the time hey
how cool is that
but envious avian with that sort of
thing you know one day you could be in
South Africa having a good horse roll
and the next thing you could be in Japan
eating fresh sashimi so who knows well
that's the thing I'm on the reserve but
I get to eat happiness is cooking all
the time and Amanda's cooking so that's
fine and Rebecca said something in might
yeah but I couldn't quite hear I think
I'm sending you off to somewhere else so
we're about to take off we'll see you
soon thanks Taylor
make sure you fasten your seat belt what
an Easter she seems to be having folks
well I am in a very big compost toilet
I'm sure you've probably seen this
before but for the newcomers if you've
never seen one this what I'm inside of
is actually them the midden or the
toilets of a White Rhino used by the
male's as a form of what you'd say
Facebook of the bush whereby all the
states are subjects related sub States
as sexual States as all of those things
are updated excuse me on a daily basis
and all those coming in to investigate
are able to to see and to check those
status so I hope that makes some sense
to those of you social media viewers out
there who don't understand it do sing
Chrissy's of arunoda toilet but let me
bring it back to why and I'm actually
covered in flies right now cuz I'm in a
toilet but it is organic it is all of
vegetarians diet and lots of flowers are
learning
my face but the reason why we stopped is
to go back on to the story of the
organic movement and nutrients back into
the soil so the rana bull versus is done
here and he feeds on a huge amount of
grass material and that grass which is
taken from the vegetation which is from
the soil is then deposited here and then
is reassimilated by many many functions
namely the dung beetle and then all
sorts of other larvae and things that
might live inside so this organic
material will be decomposed and digested
back into the soil and then what we have
as well for existing a bit of a flour
problem over there what we do have as
well is lots of activity you can see
around there all these little divots in
the ground and what has happened here
and I've got the evidence rides in front
of me you can see these beautiful
feathers of the helmeted guinea fowl the
beautiful spot pattern of the tarantella
Afrikaans name for the guinea fowl
beautiful spots and they've been coming
in and scratching and looking for all
sorts of grubs and insects that might be
living and and and surviving with inside
the organic material of the Rana midden
but not only that well you can see the
dung here's the guinea fowl dung as well
quite easy to identify by the whiteness
and because they're a vegetarian
it's very sort of CD and and grass like
in there so not like a lot of other
birds that you might find the dropping
is primarily white with a bit of a black
spot because of just what they feed on
here the vegetarian diets of seeds and
grass is what you find and certain small
bugs and insects as well but what they
often feed on guinea fowl is actually
the dead and decaying material coming
out of elephant dung and Rhino material
so they will actually feed on some fresh
vegetation as well and what they've done
here not only have their dug and sort of
looked for insects also maybe a little
bit of a of a wallow a little bit of mud
in sight not mad but soil inside the
feathers a dust bath and at the same
time they've defecated lost some
feathers and probably had an absolute
ball over time so that is me on the
story of the Rhino toilets but bringing
it back into the greatest scheme of
things this is one hot spot as you can
see when we spoke about the lion kill
there earlier look how much this area
here is different from that area over
there the organic material the nutrients
of cycle this entire thing
is an ecosystem and it is home to all
sorts of things that we can't even
perceive lots and lots of small things
going on in there and just the nice
activity of the guinea fowl here to show
us what's going on in the daily labs of
the guinea fowl and the rhinoceros but
we're gonna continue on the light is
perfect for a leopard to show itself
don't you think food definitely leopard
light
well folks we can act and see what we
got it's just that Chris vehicle
now Steve I couldn't agree more with you
that it is the perfect time of day for a
lipid to pop out onto the road somewhere
around all of this area and so what we
doing now is we're going towards gar
remain because a little whisper in my
ear says that there could be a potential
sighting of a lipid coming on suka
remain so we're just heading into that
direction and seeing if we gonna get
lucky and while we do that it's in your
custody know who has found the Easter
Bunny
very very angry that's what I'm looking
at because it is only or almost quarter
to 6:00 Central African time and this
Easter Bunny is taking a break that's
not acceptable Easter Bunny you've got
one day a year to go around and make
sure that everybody gets Easter eggs but
here you are caught red-handed having a
sleep your bus is gonna hear about this
I'm of course just joking VM spotted
this very camouflaged scrub here and
does look like a little one too just
sitting very very still just a full nose
wiggling every now and then and blinking
it maybe it fix its ears it's important
that during the day they do try and hide
themselves out of sight
Raptors my goodness lots of things
become trailing through their pack of
wild dogs a leopard on a scent marking
mission well enough to chase that need
that anyways its carrion we are also
looking for leopards now BM has insisted
that I find him one this evening he's
finding all the animals are hunting I
think I'm just driving and talking
nonsense today so all the animals you've
seen so far you can all say thank you
very much captain dr. VN which will now
be your name forever we need to make
your little wings then hey again how do
you feel about that
get you a captain's hat I can't you can
get a captain's hat and wear it
stethoscope at the same time hey you'll
be a real hit with the ladies legend you
walked into the bar like that
what you can't walk through by Katzen
zwei they're not but they can go on
holiday to PM's telling me off and
saying we shouldn't be drinking and
flying you shouldn't be drinking or
driving you should be doing any of those
things shall we take a moment seeing as
though it is the festive season for
those of you traveling please be careful
out on the roads a vibe alive take it
easy no need to speed no need to
intoxicate yourself and and do any
driving let's let's keep everybody safe
out there on well this festive holiday
everyone's of course marine excited
families are coming together you don't
want to be seeing that and unfortunately
in South Africa I'm sorry to be a debbie
downer right now but the amount of
accidents on roads is really really high
and an always over the festive season so
come on South Africans let's do it this
yeah let's bring those death tolls down
up we go and finish now I'm not going to
be sad anymore but I just thought I just
they didn't really know how important it
is to be safe Rebecca are you trying to
talk to me because I'm just hearing
beeps Bernardo know if it's you or the
game driver idea did she I didn't hear
her no can you hear what you say okay I
can't hear what's going on I can hear
sort of just beeps I think it might be
because I'm out of signal and but VM if
it's anything important you can let me
know right I don't know why I've got
ah okay perfect
Hakuna Matata Rebecca Hakuna Matata
I get real we were gonna go now I'm just
checking down around here because we did
have tomba strikes the other day oh
hello there's a blacksmith black-winged
in the road one of them the other one
you won't be able to see it's just
running off in the grass we taking off
as well it must be a pilot to carry on
let's go and see what else we can find
no no I've got no comms I think what's
happened is I'm not I don't have signal
for some reason on my radio which
happened to me the other day so no what
did she say yes
draw a bird day thank you view on the
8th of April or any of the youngsters
are they well all the adults if you want
to give it an attempt to draw us your
favorite bird maybe you what it's going
to be that blacksmith Lapwing perhaps
you can draw them and try and portray
how bossy they are and how they chase
all the other birds away maybe make a
little comic-con of it would be quite
nice and be nice to see so get get ready
for that because that's happening on the
8th of April just around the corner oh
yes I love that I Jack in here Rebecca
now ok here's another idea and for
anybody that wants to partake doesn't
matter if you can't draw it's fine
you've seen James drawings and well they
still allow him to draw life so you'll
be ok what Rebecca has suggested is what
if you drew a bird that would represent
each one of the team members from Wylder
how cool would that be can be presenters
the cameraman the directors chefs
everybody all of the people tick you
also need to hashtag draw a bird is very
important as well as well the hashtag
that you're all very familiar with
hashtag Safari live - when you do post
those pictures so that we can see I
think we're going to be connecting them
if I'm not mistaken
Rebecca can everybody can they start
posting them now can it only be posted
on
world bird day not well better you need
you need to post them ASAP as soon as
possible
Rebecca's going she needs them she needs
them and I yes so do that so it's get
them in as soon as you can before the
8th and I think we'll be sharing a
couple of them right somebody else
that's got a bird that you might like to
see you okay potentially draw is Steve
yeah thanks Tyler we have managed to
find for you
the helmeted guineafowl and there is a
flock of them here and walking through
the longer ice feeding on what looks
like the inflorescence
and seeds of the grasses that have
probably all come into full seed now
after the rains and a very very very
good nutrient source for these animals
they got to make hay while the Sun
shines so to speak and so when there are
seeds on the grasses this is when the
birds make the most of it
even find baboons and water feeding on
the seeds at the moment and those of you
who've been watching my bush walks will
see that our feed on them as well
depending on the species and they are
moving around quite safely there that
seems to be to perturb this flock on the
left of us and a herd of Impala around
and so there's lots and lots of eyes and
ears and there's just one of the camps
at the back there with one of our staff
villages
we're Taylor Starr footage there's a
beautiful Impala I haven't heard any of
the rat sing calls yet you can see the
beautiful females they're also enjoying
the seeds it looks like and they are too
looks like a couple just off to the
right yeah these boys here are started
to show a little bit of something but
there's not too much inner debt you can
tell that they are basically just using
as much time as they can to get fit so
they're feeding feeding feeding but soon
within the next few weeks there's gonna
be all sorts of testosterone and
aggression showing between these males
who obviously trying as hard as they can
to be the number one Ram and to get the
mating rights to all the females but to
do that you need
to be fit you need to be strong they
need to make sure they get in the right
amount of nutrients we got some more
over on the right sure so slowly but
surely you're gonna notice the Impala
hoods just being segregated into males
as bachelor groups and then females
large groups of females with with one or
two one with one male doing their thing
and that sound is soon to be upon us and
we'll be filling the evening and morning
and daytime air constantly as they
continue to fight and rut and to
demarcate their small territories in
hope of impregnating as many females as
possible I'm looking in the direction
those Impala looking wondering what they
were looking at there's nothing there
magic dragon the guinea fowl is
definitely like a pheasant it is part of
the galliformes family I'm not sure
where the pheasant falls into that but
they are very very similar
also known as the bushveld chicken they
are about as free-range as you can get
when it comes to chicken the first lady
wants to know if we can eat guinea fowl
eggs I'm pretty sure you could I would
say they're very similar to chicken eggs
they have got the hardest shell out of
any ground nesting bird which I find
quite incredible very very hard shell
and I've never found one intact I've
never had to break one but they will
nest just in small little bushes like
where you saw those in parlor just
underneath the bush like that they'll
they'll put a little sort of scrape in
the ground and line it with some some
grass material and they lay their eggs
there and hopefully they don't get found
by by anything but very very hard and
I'm trying to think why would they have
the hardest egg and it is eluding me I'm
sure there is a reason why they've got
the hardest egg for the size but a good
time of year for them to be breeding I
haven't seen many guinea fowl of late
but a very important to buffer species
we've got to buffer species yeah the
guinea fowl and the Empire
and both of them are very very important
for for predator food when droughts come
as a drought arrives the guinea fowl
numbers seem to increase whereas a lot
of your sort of herbivore animals they
decrease and so guinea fowl will form a
very important food source for for cats
such as leopard 2 caracal not that
caracal feed too much on Impala
but as your larger prey species average
prey species decline the guinea fowl
always seems to do very very well
and they can supplement the diet of many
many small predators and they are a
favorite of the martial eagle but very
tough to eat apparently there's that
long story of how to eat a guinea fowl
if you've all heard it before please
forgive me if I tell it one more time
the story goes and I heard this from an
old wife and you go and you get a nice
pit bull from the river and you throw
the guinea fowl into this big pots with
the pebble and you boil it for about two
days and after two days you throw away
everything and you eat the pebble that's
the story of how tough the guinea fowl
is but in fact if you do happen to have
the meat you let it hang hang for a
little bit longer with most game birds
you let it hang it almost starts to
decompose and it softens and then that
apparently works quite well
see what she wants to know if there's
any birds that lay colorful eggs and
there do there's lots of birds all of
your nesting birds here will either have
a very white egg or it might be quite
sort of blue almost like the color of
their guinea fowls face some of the
weaver birds have a very blue egg the
Aramark babblers got a very blue egg
I've never seen anything other than blue
and white and obviously all the
camouflage colors that you get I've
never seen anything I think the Robin is
also I think you're talking about a
European Robin I think their eggs are
white or blue but I'm not hundred
percent sure I hope that answers your
question
the Impala as you can see a very relaxed
we're assuming now that there's probably
no leopards in the vicinity because
everyone is head down feeding so we're
still gonna carry on hopefully find you
one before the end of the show because
that could be marvelous wouldn't it Ferg
first night back it would be great to
see a spotted cat we've seen the spotted
bird now after they've been digging in
the runner done and hopefully oh well we
are going to go over to Tristan who is
waiting for this spotted cat to approach
we are indeed we are waiting very
patiently we can hear the vehicles
slowly but surely aging their way down
towards us from a Torchwood side so it's
a little Hassan a friend that is inside
tortured and coming kind of slowly down
to this area I can just make out the
vehicles and they say they can see the
power lines that are just above me at
the moment and so I'm pretty sure
they're not too far they say that they
straight north of us but it sounds to me
like they're a little bit further east
but they are coming kind of in a
southwesterly direction which is good
news for us and hopefully husana will
make an appearance as our last minute
lipid today that's the kind of hope
anyway and so we're gonna be a bit
patient and such a it's a nice time of
the day to be sitting because sometimes
you just hear kind of birds and all
those kind of things and we've had
little West Bulls we've had Franklin's
we've had philosophy and the hippos down
it should go down because we're not far
from Sudan we just done the kind of a
little bit east of cheetah Catalan at
the
so I'm just waiting for them to kind of
all settle down and then we should start
to hear things that ours and nachos
calling so you know it's obviously
that's one thing about South Africa
that's quite interesting as opposed to
other parts of the world but generally
any time of the year you can find
animals and and as many animals as you
probably want that's the thing is none
of them are really migratory here so
they here it's just that it's more it's
easier in the winter months to find
animals the reason why is that what's
become scarce and vegetation becomes
thinner so now we struggle a little bit
with long grass and battles to see some
of the animals and this gives three
dents from vegetation and those kind of
things but it's winter
the vegetation dies back in a lot of the
leaves fall off the trees the grass dies
right down and you have a situation
where everything has to congregate
around water and so winters generally
easier to find animals it's not that
there are more animals in winter it's
just easier to find them in summer they
just spread a little bit more but they
are still the same amount of animals
within this area and you know the
situation where most of them are still
here so any time of the year it just
depends on what you like in what you're
looking for for me I always find like I
say spring and I suppose spring actually
weed and early summer is probably got
more animals than any other time of year
because that's when all the babies are
born slowly be sure you they get killed
as they start growing up and you start
to lose a number of them so it's
probably the most animals we have is
actually at that time but seeing the
most animals probably more winter time
than anything else touching go and say I
mean ever seen we get big herds of
Buffalo as well now I'm trying to listen
to the update as well of what's
happening within with husana I can't
hear the cause anymore maybe he's gone
stationary for now you know how he is
he's up and down and up and down up and
down so I'm just trying to listen very
carefully and see no doesn't sound like
anything at all it sounds like a
situation where these guys maybe just
maybe have gone stationary for Nardo so
it's complicating the issue because one
of the guys that was coming to the
sighting has just found the tortured
pride
monga remain but way further down near
the
in coral side so it's kind of blocked up
the radio a little bit so I'm just
waiting to get an update on asana
himself but I don't hear the vehicles
anymore which gives me an idea that
maybe he's stationed me whenever an
animal's mobile you'll hear the vehicles
moving and you get a clanging of trees
and as they follow through the thickets
but as soon as they go station II
obviously everyone turns off anything
that returns back to quiet so he's got a
bit of time to kind of get yeah that's
hopefully he doesn't take too long about
us and hopefully doesn't just lie down
and sleep in that area but it'll be
interesting to see if he does come back
to Chitra because it seems as though
Dingaan has hit it this way and so has
that new male last night headed towards
check landing sort of cuts South No
tattooed girl the age of the oldest
leopard on Duma currently would be
probably 10 Ghana and then tungee so the
two of them are about 12 years old those
are the oldest one is at the moment and
yeah there's no one really in shadow
obviously so those three are all of a
very similar age around 12 everybody
else is quite a lot younger and sure
dudu is only about four vasanas it's not
even just gone to Tambor's not even two
and then you've got Coco Marie who we
think is around six seven years old so
they're all much young individuals than
them and hopefully we're going to get a
really nice kind of youthful set of
lipids that are gonna situate themselves
on Juma because that will be the future
of what we're going to see over the next
couple years
good now while we sit and just kind of
wait and I'll try to get an update on
the radio let's send you back across to
Taylor who's looking at probably the
fluffiest animal that we have Archer the
fluffiest animal indeed it's the water
back the reindeers of Africa I suppose
the closest thing that resembles a
reindeer and just three young water buck
balls they have just popped past Babu
and pan and little Gauri to have a bit
of a drink he's got a nice display of
horns
there are birds that are going ballistic
just out of my reach and it's
frustrating me because I can't go in
there and I'm almost certain that
there's a leopard or some cat moving
around we've been listening to these
birds alarming starting a little bit
further south to us and then sort of
passing where those water
[ __ ] are going to the wastes are going
to the right-hand side and it's like
they're flying up from the ground and
going to trees and then they do that
very nervous sort of Franklin call that
we all love to hear when we're tracking
where's the helping hand and tells us
well what we could potentially expect
but sadly nothing just yet and we had a
good look around on Chitra but
unfortunately didn't find him was that
oh no it's a other water pack I could
hear a sound and it actually was that
water back on the right walking through
that sort of marshy section was sort of
sludging and first of it was elephants
breaking branches
I'm also very cautious and they'll be
listening to what the birds are having
to say I could potentially determine
which route they take so pity we didn't
get much of a sunset tonight but what a
beautiful evening nonetheless all right
off we go what we're gonna do now is I
think we're gonna start checking some of
the boundaries just having a deep and
find hideout in a minute I just have a
feeling we might get lucky and catch a
cat so I'm going to follow my gut and
hope you think - well when it's a cat
and I hope Tristan manages to get a full
sauna - I'm not really sure where he is
if you could actually see the tread of
it further back behind us right well
we're gonna navigate through this well
gremlin infested Road and off you go
to Steve to see what he's up to
thank you very much Taylor's having
gremlins on Easter or is it Easter
gremlins I'm not quite sure the
afternoon is beautiful I love this
temperature it is that time of view is
just between the heats of summer and the
coolness of winter where you don't need
too many warm clothes but it definitely
it's nice the change of the seasons and
it's perfect weather for animals that
aren't as fat as their goomahs to be
moving around and goomer's aren't gonna
go anywhere folks I'm pretty sure about
that they're going to lie there maybe
have a drink or two from time to time
but I'm pretty sure they'll be exactly
where we left them tomorrow the only
difference is the smell will have gone
up quite a degree which Ferg and I are
ready we're commenting on it was quite
marvelous forever eyes peeled for their
every elusive spotted cat
it's a perfect time of day for the
Predators to be moving ie Nizar up at
this time leopards lions if they're
around definitely this is when we have
our best opportunity of spotting them
and the moon is still gonna be quite
bright we had moon I think - when was
filming last night is it tonight I
actually think that it might be blue
mint last night last night was a blue
moon those of you you know where the
blue moon is it's when we have two full
moons in the same calendar month and the
last blue moon that we had ours up in
the Maasai Mara and it was a super moon
it was a Blood Moon it was just
unbelievable and definitely what is my
experience is predators don't do very
well on moon at night
so the moon will be arising 51 minutes
or so after the sunset and it's gonna be
a very bright night so there won't be
too much I don't think too much movement
with regards to cats if they do move
what I find is they like to do territory
marking they like to call that actually
patrol their boundaries because hunting
is not their best time it's not the best
time planting because they just stand
out in the field of gold they're walking
through and the Predators ability to
hunt is the camouflage that they have
and if they move quietly but they're
visible it is not very helpful for for
them but you never know you never know
maybe before the moon comes up the Sun
has only set about half an hour ago so
it's full still time but it's just
wonderful to be back up you know I did
go and leave but I didn't really go into
city or anything like that so I've been
in the wilderness this entire time which
has been magical my hearts are still
quite full with with the wilderness and
the smells and the sounds quite often
I'll go some way and end up in
Johannesburg or Cape Town and then by
the time you come back it takes you two
or three days just to to shake off the
city don't know if anybody can relate to
that
but the smells and the sounds are
already here which is great Adame takes
a few days to for them to overwhelm me
again
Sam you Sam you nine years old what a
marvelous question he asked do birds
ever attack guards on game drives well
one of the birds that is quite the
Taurus for attacking people is a called
a crowned Lapwing I will find it for you
and they like to hang out on golf
courses and when people play golf they
get a bit too close to the lapwings
nests and the lapwings will dive-bomb
them but I believe David got a technical
foul on driver shape everything is after
David seems if there's ever a charge
last night they've completed in the face
by now well I've never heard of that
before
but it obviously happens and it'd be
fine too where are you you crowned there
we go let me show you quickly these
birds are notorious for dive-bombing
people on golf courses it's purely
because you get very close to very close
to the nest and then the dive-bomber
I've also seen blacksmith lapwings which
is probably let's go this way that one
they also have been quite known to
dive-bomb people but I've never been hit
by one but I know of many a golfer that
has taken a few of those birds to the
head but other than that I don't know of
any other birds that deliberately attack
people we are quite big and they might
just dive bomb you just to move you away
but to physically actually do what the
owl did today of last night I don't know
maybe had maybe had something in his
hair
he is quite a marvelous head of hair
that man so who knows he might have
unknowingly had something in there that
the owl went for maybe thought it was a
nest or a scrub here I don't know
[Laughter]
thought it was a living nest yeah
well David's gonna leave now so I didn't
even get to find out about that story
you will have to ever checked with me
about that another time and we will mock
him
okay where we gonna go to Tristan
because he's actually a first eyewitness
on the scene let's see what he has to
say I was indeed it was pretty funny I'm
not gonna lie I was just driving along
and they don't send out the corner of my
eye I just saw this thing flying
straight towards one of the guys that I
know well I mean say sorry one of the
guys that I know is about to come past
me now so I just wanna quickly check to
him
I'll give me two seconds and I'll carry
on with my story other words good
vasanas it's going to yeah they're you
know where they cross there okay perfect
okay perfect just bad sorry buddy there
we go so we're just saying sorry to
Peter because we parked him in a place
where he says a little bit of an issue
to try and get fast as a big torch
retreat that he's what's in there but as
we're saying put David was hits in the
face this bird literally flew straight
into him I thought it was gonna veer
away because we often we have the knife
jars that kind of fly in and they just
kind of do these things and then they
just turn at the last second but last
night that didn't happen it was just
funny this bird just literally flew
straight into his face and David was
ducking out the way and then it kind of
flew away from him from there it is
pretty funny to watch and the bird was
unharmed David was unharmed and so all
was good now the lights for the cars
that are following husana as you can see
are right here coming straight towards
us at the moment so they are the lights
over there are following him and
hopefully we are going to get a view of
husana imminently it should be kind of
some way in that general vicinity he
should pop out so he is moving down
towards us at the moment and so we are
gonna hopefully get a last-minute
Lepidus is a few minutes still to go and
like I say he is moving this way the
problem is is kind of going way softly
so it's taking longer than it should to
get towards us but I'm gonna keep going
back
andrew chances of a leopard taking down
a fully grown buffalo is almost zero or
fully grown bull Buffalo a fully grown
female possible and the reason why I say
is pretty much zero it's only time that
it would be possible is in a time of
drought when you've got a situation
where you've got Buffalo that are really
really weak and are in a situation where
they're not able to really hunt
effectively then you would have a
problem so I'm just trying to get back
because apparently hisana is mobile
quickly to the west now rather than the
south and so I'm just trying to kind of
see where he is so text is not calling
me as oh okay attacks yeah we can see in
the lights so please excuse the lights
with the infrared it does sometimes make
it a little bit more kind of difficult
but you can see husana kind of bouncing
along through the thickets he is going
to come pretty much straight towards us
so we will have him at some point we
just need to kind of get ourselves into
a good position but at least that's a
glimpse and he is hitting our way so the
chances of us not seeing him nicely is
pretty slim but at least we're going to
have a little bit of time as well I
thought maybe we were gonna be foiled by
time but it seems as though we're gonna
get this right so piston you say come on
boys show your pretty face well I think
he's going to try and show us he's
pretty favorable we gonna hope that he's
gonna shine show us his pretty face he
is kind of moving towards us so he
trying to follow the lights at the
moment it seems as though he is kind of
between us and where that vehicle is and
kind of moving in our direction
so hopefully we will spot him shortly
very close to the road that's what I'm
hoping for I'm just trying to add a bit
of light so that I can actually see
what's going on because it's not easy to
see at all at the moment and he's moving
so quickly that it's seriously difficult
to kind of keep up with what's going on
and I'm trying to reverse and not hit
any cars that could potentially be
coming down this main road
listen to somebody we really had one
accident this week with brains we don't
need to have another one
so he's somewhere in this general
vicinity where those cars are I think
he's still hitting a little further away
it was he on the branch there he's
behind the big bushes Craig says to me
so that's where Craig is saying he is at
the moment but he is moving so it's okay
as long as he keeps moving these things
you kind of come to our side hopefully
is heading straight West from what I
hear and not south which is not ideal so
just kind of try and avoid some trees
that I didn't hit myself on the back of
the head even though it's probably not
the worst thing to do shake up the old
brain of it
so here's probably gonna be our best
shot to see him hopefully he's gonna
come straight down this road at us so
what I'm hoping is he's walking West and
then he's going to kind of just veer
southwards towards me so he should come
out somewhere there I'm gonna use a bit
of light just to help because of how far
it is the infrared it's going to stay
there we go
hello boy well done Craig you spotted
him there and he's still moving
westwards he's not actually coming south
yet so the situation where they're going
to have to reverse further I was hoping
that we're gonna see him kind of coming
towards straight towards me but being a
young man and he's on his own little
kind of idea of where he wants to go so
hopefully he will kind of head in this
direction there's a big termite mound
there let's just stop here maybe he's
gonna go up onto the termite mound no
nothing seems as though he's coming
you can see that there's lights being
shun there is he's coming straight
towards us I'm just gonna go back
slightly just so that we can not kind of
cut him off his path but there he is
right there excellent news hello boy
you've been on a big walk there today so
we've tracked him all over the place
trying to kind of follow him and you
Vincent - tortured and Rex and found him
about 400 metres from where we had his
last track so he obviously just behind
him the whole afternoon but isn't he
looking fantastic and the fact that he
stayed on Juma even though he had this
incident with Haku Marie goes to show
that he's not that afraid at the moment
and so whether that's a good thing or a
bad thing I'm not quite sure but either
way it's so epic to have a liquid to
finish the show and you can see he's
just kind of ambling right past us as he
does so I'm just going to try and stay
out the way of the infrared lights and
straight across into chitwa chitwa is is
where he's going so we're gonna try and
see if we can keep up with him it's at
least not too thick the way that he's
walking it's kind of nice and open so
it'll be perfectly okay to follow him
through yeah well should be so I'm going
to do such and try and keep up with him
and try and see if we can work out where
he's off to maybe we'll bump into ting
gana on the way as well because there's
a situation waiting Ghana came this side
- so sorry Craig let me turn off my
lights because it's going to make the
infrared and what as bright so what
we're gonna do is we're just gonna
follow him around there's a nice big
fallen over tree here that I'm hoping he
might actually decide to go up slowly
ambling down sniffing around I think
he's probably on the prowl as well they
said to me they was chasing waters just
now you can see all the dust that just
came off him and he plunged his head
into a hole trying to get after a wart
ugh and something he's hungry which
means that he's gonna probably be moving
around trying to find food hello it was
a curious face that he's always caught
very cool cats so fortunate that we've
got a cat like this
in our area he really provides us with
the most insane amounts of entertainment
and such an intriguing character to
follow so very very cool and what a way
for us to finish our Easter Sunday don't
you think Eiling is a perfect way to
finish Easter Sunday we've had lions
we've had elephants we've had pretty
much everything that all of us like now
sorry Craig I'm going to have to use the
lights because otherwise I can't see
where I'm going and that's going to need
in us having an accident which I'm
pretty sure Craig doesn't want us to
have so we'll try and kind of keep the
lights on for now also need to get
hauled a chat with everybody and let
them know that we have crossed a South
with this leopard the guys in the East
so they can come as well now while we do
that I'm gonna send you back across to
Taylor mccurdy who's still looking
around for some little Nights critters
yep I am looking for night critters and
Dresden if I bump into you you'll be the
first one that I find haha I don't think
we're gonna see comedians on a night
like tonight I think it's a bit chilly
and babe let me just say maybe a bush
baby and then baby came on maybe a bush
baby I lost not I actually saw him very
quickly it just bounced from bronze and
now Rebecca is singing baby baby but
baby I'm not gonna do that because I
can't sing but hopefully that song is
not also stuck in your head like it will
be in mind for the rest of the evening
anyways and maybe a night jar and owl
would be really cool I would not mind
them as seeing an owl spotted eagle owl
in particular I feel like it's been a
long time since since I put one on
camera I don't know if I've ever put a
spotted eagle owl in the sabi sand I
think a tomorrow
did I I can't remember anyways when I
went out for a safari in bubbles hook
we did see a really cool SWAT vehicle I
was so relaxed it was quite happy to
just sit on a wood pile and I think they
were living up in the sort of rafters of
this fetched area during the day that's
with her getting the shade and cool and
well nice cool spots were very clever of
them and then it was just sitting on the
wood pile which was epic so you could
get nice
very obliging normally owls are not the
most obliging of the nocturnal critters
Scots are one that calls in camp every
single night oh by the way he just ran
change of topic because I forgot to tell
you we didn't really play cricket today
brained Tristan
Conrad David who else waned to be him
I don't know who else wound just briefly
played I mean there was all practicing
before tomorrow I think it was just the
boys I decided to give it a bit of a
skip I'm going to go I definitely won't
play but I think tomorrow is the
official cricket game the weather was
also a bit miserable I think everyone
was tired but where are really there'll
be sweet hands and half time cooler
boxers with nice cold waters we still
haven't done orange slices yet like I've
been saying oh and we've got you guys
haven't even heard I don't know if
anybody said we hadn't have a new person
working for wild earth now his name is
Luke hi Luke
and Luke is going to be training up to
be a director he just laughed at me
good that's the response that one should
sort of give back to me just laugh and
shake your hand here and then move away
swiftly before I say something weird and
so here we go hopefully we'll be able to
show you what loop looks like he's from
the coast the East Coast been raining on
in all the people from the coast from
Durban from the kzn and I think he told
me when to Glenwood high school I'm not
mistaken securities history his ID
number is now I'm just joking I'm not
going to give you that information
don't be silly is that could it possibly
be could it possibly be a chameleon or
not real oh yes please please be one
Christ I can click place I VM let me go
closer
I was excited booth that was a very
excited noise I did there it is a
chameleon
Hey hi chameleon say hello okay we're
gonna stay here because I chameleons not
gonna go anyway so I'm going to send you
Tristan with husana who's moving quickly
well Masana is moving very very fast
he's kind of coming towards us now and
he was actually watching a Easter Bunny
so he wants his Easter Bunny snack as
well and he's just standing now watching
where this little scrub here ran in
front of our car so he's looking as
stately as ever isn't he looking
magnificent the way that he's standing
now is starting to show that he's
getting bigger and bigger but a nice
board chase starting to develop and even
a little bit of a julep and really is
looking like an impressive male and so
funny I this particular spot that he's
standing right now I have seen in Doudna
I have seen in Siobhan B'Elanna I've
seen husana and I have seen I'm just
trying to think of who the other one was
one of the other offspring of korilla
all in this exact same kind of position
and all in all the males or when they
were distributing fat gather mail was
not any of Krugers off-screen it was
tortured that was the other mail that I
saw in this area and so they've all used
this particular section as young
individuals that move around now you can
see he's kind of just trying to walk
right past our vehicle hitting straight
down to a lodge the trees off to he's
going to be making his way towards the
dam itself and is going to probably hid
there you can see the lights of chitra
Lodge in the background so something
about chatter makes husana very very
happy and makes him hid in that
direction regularly it seems to always
kind of go there and move that way now
like I said this is gonna be a spotlight
so with that infrared I do apologize if
it flares it's just unfortunately the
guests that are out there they can't see
with just their eyes and they don't have
the ability to have an infrared beam you
can see how it doesn't care about cause
we literally just walks right around him
and kind of carries on as there they are
mean nothing so we're going to go around
and try and keep up now there's a lot of
different vehicles that I want to come
here Tinh Ghana apparently went into an
area where it was very difficult so I
don't know how much longer we're gonna
have with him we're probably only gonna
have the next two three minutes or so
and then we're gonna probably have to
start thinking about giving others a
chance even though we were patient and
waited it's the same kind of story is
that the guys made space for us when we
found him and so you know any games
needs to be the same way right now what
I'm hoping is that he's gonna go for a
little drink of water he's just gonna
park right as hoping is gonna go for a
drink of water and then towards a
termite mound but it seems as though
he's going to change direction now and
head straight out of our area Sanne
you can't come under the car boy it's
going to try anyway so there he goes
he's just crossing off in two little
gauri unfortunately which is not ideal
I'm gonna try and just go forward a
little bit so there he goes he's going
kind of in towards little Gauri and out
of our area so that's the last viewing
aim to get of him which is still
fantastic at least we got to see him and
it needs to be got a chance to watch our
boy moving around good now from one
nocturnal creature that is very exciting
to another one that we've hardly seen
over the last few weeks and that is a
very special one and I'm not sure who's
got it but it will be exciting it's me
Tristan I has it i has the chameleon I'm
just joking I can actually speak English
I have the chameleon everybody whoo-hoo
you don't understand how excited I am
because I've been searching far and wide
for you were also in infrared as you can
see and normally the chameleons are
green in color but we've decided to keep
the spotlight off of this fella and
we'll just let it go about its day all
ready to hold on for the night it's got
its feet tightly wound on the edge of
this large fruited bush wallow and it
doesn't look like it's got any intention
and going anywheres it's just does it
close its eyes being was it looking away
[ __ ] looking away remember those eyes
can move round and round
all different types of directions so I
think it might just be trying to look
behind them and they do have a blind
spot at the back of their heads they
can't see what's going on back because I
was working so hard you know you should
be in bed now obviously crawled out from
the denser vegetation where it would
have been hiding away from birds and
snakes and other types of critters that
will want to eat it and now hanging out
on a skin a little stem and just
enjoying the nice cool evening and it's
quite a big flap net chameleon - it's
not a small one it's if I made a fist
with my hand it's probably the size of
that so a decent size in fact looks very
fat and healthy now but some lizards
they often store the fat in their tails
I don't know if chameleons do that
because I've never seen chameleons of
sort of you know and sort of really
really sort of fat and thick tails and
normally relatively slender but you do
see that with a lot of the lizards they
store all the fat in the end of the tail
and then they'll use that when well
times are tough but yeah we've got a
chameleon finally it seems as though
Steve has managed to find his way back
at the Lions I'm pretty sure from where
we are I could hear them contact calling
let's just have a quick listen we've got
one-liners feeding
just yeah that sort of generates a like
sound
is annoying on the cervical vertebra
the kuru caucus is still hidden by those
bushes so he can't actually see what
that - is doing just like really we
couldn't really see it but you just hear
the noises coming from behind that Bush
Jill listen and what are they trying to
say when their contact core and they're
just trying to communicate with each
other try call the the family members
that might be close by calling the Cubs
beautiful see slowly four four cubs were
thoughtful locating there is the pride
use our spotlight in the front yeah just
to get a little bit of illumination
there's absolutely no visual